bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouvel
épisode de probablement j'accueille
florian boutière journaliste
scientifique alias curio log temps sur
twitter bonjour au plan je pas dit betty
c'est toi non c'est bon dos qui fera ce
que tu pourras pas te présenter
notamment ton parcours commence que tu
es devenu ce qu'était devenu au la
grosse question
et alors donc je suis florian gouttière
effectivement ça jusque là tout va bien
je suis j'ai été essentiellement
journaliste scientifique pendant de
longues années
mais en même temps médiateur
scientifique donc à un travail qui a
trait de près la vulgarisation sous
diverses formes
je suis arrivé au journalisme par la
vulgarisation je n'ai jamais lâché la
médiation humaine et vivante pendant
toutes les années où c'est où le
journalisme a été mon activité
principale
généralement on me demande quel a été le
parcours pour arriver à faire du
journalisme scientifique ce alors après
un bac s est lié à une très forte
appétence pour les sciences ou pro
l'idée que je me faisais des sciences en
tout cas j'ai fait une école faire une
année de formation en école de cinéma
est ce que je voulais faire la
vulgarisation j'avais envie de raconter
voilà raconter les sciences c'est à lui
que je me les imaginait je pensais
raconter les sur ce court mais quelque
chose me plaisait pas dans le monde du
cinéma
on me disait que les gens vont avoir des
films pour réfléchir ils ont uniquement
pour ce faire se divertir pour dire les
choses poliment et ça c'est pas ça n'a
pas beaucoup plu en même temps je me
disais la quitte à parler des sciences
autant ceux à se blinder donc je suis
revenu assez rapidement vers des études
scientifiques en faisant une chose qui
ressemblait un peu à une prépa intégrée
et les sciences ça me plaisait mais
finalement les sciences à l'université
c'est pas le des sciences delcamp cela
représente enfin de moi dans mon enfance
j'étais mon personnage favori c'était
léonard de vinci
à léonard qui ressemble à la fois à la
boyer pena bd léonard mais aussi au
personnage historique je lisais beaucoup
de choses sur ce personnage et je
faisais mes propres carnets de léonard
dans lequel je m'étais mais les grandes
hypothèses sur le monde
voilà quand les dix ans et aubry sur
pourquoi les dinosaures ont disparu
et puis voilà j'étais content de j'avais
l'impression que émettre ces hypothèses
suffisait à faire des sciences que
c'était très facile de devenir inventeur
géo trouvetou pour moi ça pouvait être
un métier quoi il était quoi ton
hypothèse sur les dinosaures chez les
dinosaures étaient liés à la
radioactivité
la radioactivité du sol et à partir des
cartes de radioactivité les zones on
avait retrouvé les fossiles en cinquième
vu que c'était dans les manuels on
voyait les cartes de radioactivité du
sol je m'étais demandé si on pouvait
faire une corrélation avec la les zones
on a retrouvé les fossiles est ce que ça
il n'y avait pas une radioactivité
beaucoup plus forte du sous-sol à
l'époque mais et qui aurait eu un effet
et j'ai noté ça dans mes carnets avec
des jolis dessins et du papier calque
pour voir si même en décalant le enfin
si jamais il ya une inversion des pôles
après ce que la terre a basculé un petit
peu comme une une bulle autour d'une
d'un noyau plus dur est ce qu'on ne fait
pas en trouver un autre angle pour faire
corps et les ces choses là une glace et
de l'exploration c'était un bon c'était
ça valait ce que ça valait quand on
quand on est en 5e on est on est ouvert
à tout ça semble être une démarche une
démarche de découverte une démarche de
formulation des hypothèses bref donc je
m'aperçois à l'université que c'est pas
tout à fait ça mais ça m'intéresse et je
me disais que ça me ferait bien de
fabriquer des pompes pour et c'était un
objet très très intéressant le point
comment ça peut tenir
comment ces structures jeu j'étais
rentré dans cette prépa un peu un gène
year vers la géologie géotechnique
géophysique
et puis parce que les maths était
vraiment exigeante et que j'avais un peu
perdu durant les années à prendre durant
l'année de cinéma et aussi à cause à
cause du fait que les filles un peu
séché les cours à la fac et j'ai dû
retaper ma de mon deuxième semestre de
2e année de de physique et de maths et
là je me suis dit qu'est ce que je vais
faire du reste de mon année redoubler
les amis mali soit qui aime raconter des
histoires pourquoi tu t'inscris ray pas
en lettres modernes date inscrire en
lettres modernes ça va t'occuper situe à
nourrir ta plume et réfléchir à des
questions de narration enfin voilà et
donc voilà j'ai mené ensuite de front
les les deux les lettres modernes à la
fac et les écoles enfin sciences pour
l'ingénieur quoi la filière sciences
pour l'ingénieur et donc je me suis
retrouvé assez rapidement avec un bagage
audiovisuel un bagage scientifique e et
un bagage littéraire est en fait ce qui
était intéressant pendant ces années là
où ce que j'avais appris sur les bancs
de la fac
c'était de m'apercevoir que les gens ne
se comprenaient pas que quand j'arrivais
à en cours de l'être
déjà j'étais à le scientifique assez
bizarre qu'ils avaient des idées reçues
énorme qui était un peu les miennes
avant que je me confronte à aux
expériences de labo réflexion de
certains enseignants et inversement
erin une incompréhension totale entre
les deux qui est comme clichés c'est
plein de choses assez subtil mais de
quand je me souviens que quand on
regarde et les cours de linguistique
quand mes collègues de en cours de
finition voyez que j'avais un cours de
linguistique dans as
il disait que ça n'avait aucune valeur
que c'était c'est pas des sciences que
c'était il s'en moquer comme c'est un
peu quelque chose d ôter riquet pour eux
voilà la linguistique ça pouvait pas
être une chance c'est sûr c'était
forcément de la physique et moi ça
m'intéressait beaucoup c'est de
travailler sur ces incompréhensions
mutuelles
et de m'apercevoir que si je voulais
expliquer ce que je faisais au sein je
devais trouver un autre langage est une
autre façon de parler ouais et j'ai
rencontré des gens très intéressants
pendant ces années-là qui faisait
notamment des erasmus qui bossait sur la
communication interculturelle
donc c'était plutôt comment les
allemands peuvent parler aux français
comment les expatriés au cambodge vont
arriver à monter leur boîte sont heurter
les représentations culturelles etc
en fait je me suis aperçu que ça pouvait
être transposée dans le monde des
sciences et des lettres vient donc donc
voila et il se trouve que par hasard en
trompant de couloir je devais à lire un
cours de chinois et je me sens pas être
courageuse variés dans le couloir des à
la fac de paris-7 de journalisme
scientifique
j'ai dit à jean qui j'avais des parcours
assez libéré aussi et quand en discutant
avec un prof
il m'a dit voilà vous avez le profil
pour revenir c'est un peu con les les
examens c'est aujourd'hui en fin c'était
aujourd'hui qu'il fallait s'inscrire
pour c'est comme ça que ça s'est passé
at il trompé de couloir talent et un
prof et j'ai fait le forcing et en
faisant le jeu peut venir faire l'examen
j'avais donc à l'année d'après j'ai
commencé journalisme scientifique et à
une heure près un couloir couloir près
alors bravo
c'est dans ce sens là je serais venu une
semaine avant ça ferait pas aussi
ésotérique mais reste donc voilà
et je suis arrivée là dedans avec des
idées en tête
c'est à dire que je découvrais qu'en
fait c'était c'était c'est pas que
journalisme scientifique c'était
journalisme et communication
scientifique et technique et j'étais
très intéressé par vulgariser des choses
qui me semblait être délaissés par les
sciences par par préjugé et beaucoup de
choses qui selon moi faisait très
probablement partie du champ des
sciences mais qui étaient délaissées
parce que les champs c'est quelque chose
de très dogmatique et très conservatif
caisse conservateur pardon parce que
finalement les enseignements que j'avais
durant les année de deug donc
l'équivalent en l1 l2 maintenant là
c'était vraiment du savoir traits d un
ange avait pas eu l'occasion d'avoir des
cours de ou des cours potable les cours
qui ne satisfaisait en tout cas de
philosophie des sciences
et puis d'autres histoires des sciences
sans beaucoup de perspective
philosophique oui c'était ma logique à
l'époque
et donc voilà je me suis basse s'arrête
l'occasion de faire dialoguer ces
disciplines et est donc voila mon projet
c'était de faire du d'être capable de
vulgariser des choses délaissé par
l'intérêt scientifique et qui sont avec
leurs plus hauts gratte en fait s'avérer
des pseudosciences quoi elle est ce que
j'avais une amie qui travaillait qu'il
était sensibilisé elle travaillait pas
au sens professionnel mais un travail
sur elle-même passer par ce qu'on
appelle les constellations familiales et
une théorie très ésotérique de fait que
tu peux représenter les problèmes
familiaux en plaçant des gens dans une
pièce unique toi tu va symboliser mon
père tu as symbolisait ma mère qui met
les gens à une certaine distance les uns
des autres et qui tuent les interroge
que ce qu'ils ont ressenti leur ressenti
pour révéler des choses que tu n'avais
pas compris sur sur le vécu dépendra je
me souviens que mon père ma vie
comme si soudain tu te connecter à un
univers cosmique
je les hais la sas et il ya des
expériences qui sont faites et des
expériences en fait est qu'il ya des
conclusions qui sont formulés sans
forcément valide et puis c'est dans ces
années là que je me suis que ma boulimie
de lecture etc a amené à ce qu'on
appelle le scepticisme scientifique aux
auteurs de vulgariser la zététique
toujours à nice et celui que j'étais
dans la filière journalisme sur internet
je faisais mes études de skate et est en
fait puisque j'étais là pour la volonté
c'était de remettre en cause les
préjugés des autres sas ont créé le
prétentieuse quoi je me suis je vais
commencer par les miens et c'était une
déconstruction rapide mais de mes
illusions j'étais dans les choses que je
voulais vulgarisée par exemple c'était
le matin des magiciens de voeux de
howell ces derniers mois une séance et
ses oeuvres lac qui mettait en avant le
réalisme fantastique et qui montrait une
autre façon de penser l'accession au
savoir les moyens de découvrir des
savoir est-ce que pourquoi est ce qu'on
n'en parle pas quand j'essaie de
comprendre pourquoi on n'en parle pas
c'est parce que c'était limite que
c'était des choses qui s'était jamais
vérifier donc
en utilisant les techniques que
j'apprenais en école de journalisme de
vraiment là ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui
le fait chez king mais de vérification
des sources de essayé d'interroger sur
comment est-ce que c'est outre ses
auteurs affirment des choses et donc ils
ont des sources donc on revient à ses
sources à 1000 faut pas s'arrêter à ces
sources cela quels ont été les méthodes
employées par les personnes qui ont
produit ces ses sources pour valider
enfin quand une fois qu'ils ont mis sur
le marché us cette idée est ce qu elles
ont juste avant de mettre sur le marché
ce qu'ils ont tout mis en oeuvre pour
vérifier qu'ils se plantent et parfois
et ça ça m'a guidé bon toutes les années
suivantes ces jeux et les jouets les
construit beaucoup de choses j'avais de
la peu d'avancé sur ces questions quand
j'étais gamin mon père était et est très
intéressée par ce réalisme fantastique
et quand il me faisait me raconter le
monde quand ils me racontaient
les animaux dans la forêt comme cipra
compter pourquoi est ce que tout ce que
nos parents nous racontent sur l'automne
les feuilles qui tombent parfois ils me
parlaient aussi là des pistes de l'asca
où il est fort probable que des
vaisseaux atterrissent elle a fait
partie de ce qu'on appelait le savoir à
connotation scientifique archéologie
suspicion qui peut-être des des ballons
des ballons à chauffer à la fin avec de
l'air chaud qui s'élevait pour dédé
l'époque précolombienne enfin tout ça ça
faisait partie d'un même univers le
savoir les sciences les savoirs
collectifs que tout le monde ce que tous
ne plein plein de doit savoir tout le
monde doit savoir que qu' il ya des des
bas-reliefs chez les mayas qui
représenterait peut-être des vaisseaux
spatiaux ça doit faire partie de l'un
savoir que tout le monde doit avoir été
surpris que tout le monde ne soit pas au
courant
et puis il se trouve que bâle à force de
lire tout et n'importe quoi et d'adorer
la pratique de la prestidigitation
je me suis trouvé dans un bouquin
précise de prestidigitation avoir des
dessins qui représentait les trucs les
secrets derrière des des séances de
lévitation que j'avais vu dans des
bouquins de mon père et était présenté
au premier degré bien qu'elle et ça ça
c'est parti dans les choses qui ont
nourri ma réflexion
tiens c'est marrant les auteurs ils sont
fait avoir sur un truc est pas tout
vérifier voilà le bouquin est vachement
bien fait mais là dessus je m'aperçois
que sur les limitations et ils se sont
fait avoir par un faux semblants par un
faux semblants par une vision paraît
normal et je considérais que c'est pas
parce qu'ils sont fait avoir sur un truc
que tout le reste était faux ça
m'intéresse aurait dû m'interroger sur
la la validité de la méthode de ses
auteurs pour produire ces gros bouquin
qui se vendent
qui sont écrire ce qu'ils font écrit
vite et malines qui se vendent comme des
petits pains en quoi donc arriver à ce
niveau d'eau dans cette fac et ben j'ai
tout remis à plat et ses interrogations
que j'avais à plaquer à chaque fois très
ponctuellement main commun comme à cette
anecdote de la lévitation j'essayais de
les appliquer a beaucoup plus de choses
avant de vulgariser avant de vulgariser
quoi que ce soit va essayer de remonter
aux sources et de trouver des méthodes
et des méthodes valide pertinente pour
évaluer remonter aux sources
ouais et donc la question ne s'est pas
fait cette démarche intellectuelle est
ce que ca représentatives des gens qui
étaient en journée de scientifiques
en fait on était tous là pour des
raisons différentes dans cette filière
qui se trouve donc à paris cet essai
d'une filière un peu particulière les
gens qui viennent là et ils viennent un
peu en reconversion
parce qu'ils ont fait des études qui
leur plaisent pas tout à fait qu'ils ont
une appétence pour la vulgarisation
donc il y avait des gens qui on allait
tous des raisons différentes dettes la
main qu'ils voulaient voir s'il avait
envie de faire du journalisme qui
appelait qui sont allés vers les écoles
plus plus coté là dedans donc à épier
inversement il y avait des gens qui
étaient vraiment dans une démarche
beaucoup plus avancé que moi sur ces
réflexions là et qu'ils voulaient
trouver des nouveaux outils pour mener
ses enquêtes à mais en fait chacun était
différent dans ce dans cette filière est
donc par un dalon quand j'ai commencé à
rencontrer d'autres personnes qui
faisait du journalisme scientifique des
journalistes qui ont envie de parler des
sciences
je me suis aperçu que y en avait qui
étaient très bien formés qui passait par
des filières qui les nourrissent et de
ses questionnements et et beaucoup
d'autres qui fit qui considérait que
c'était superflu mais et puis j envoie
aussi des gens qui ne viennent pas de
filière on forme à penser et à parler
les sciences ou un milliard les
élections
mais les personnes dont ils font du
journalisme généraliste mais qui ont un
goût des sciences et qui vont se mettre
à parler de science laquelle qui se les
représente
alors y en a qui se cassent les dents
assez vite sur sur le fait que comme ils
sont curieux et qu'ils ont des
ressources de curiosité ils vont
s'apercevoir que l'idée qu'ils se font
des sciences là c'est pas tout à fait ça
à la réalité la réalité terrain quand il
se pose des questions sur les conflits
d'intérêt quand il se pose des questions
sur sur pourquoi est ce que cette étude
finalement l'étude du lundi à l'étude du
mardi gras sont contradictoires
ça leur pose les questions et en
creusant milow vienne devenu journaliste
malgré le fait qu'ils aient pas de
culture scientifique y sont obligés de
se la faire il se lâche on trouve des
noms de journalistes qui sont soumis au
silence sans savoir une formation
scientifique font un travail excellent
ouais mais retrouve beaucoup plus
fréquemment malheureusement j'ai pas
fait nos statistiques précises mais
c'est un constat que j'ai fait de très
nombreuses fois où des journalistes
scientifiques qui parle des sciences à
partir des idées reçues qu'ils ont sur
les chances qui les remettent jamais en
question et qui enfin j'en ai rencontré
plusieurs domaines en particulier la
question c'est pourquoi est ce que tu es
devenu un journaliste spécialiste en
écologie mali c'est parce qu'un jour en
conférence de rédaction l'a dit on m'a
dit toi tu mange bio donc tu vas parler
écologie elle avait pas de le compléter
autre que son goût pour le bio quoi et
quand on voit que voilà elle était
spécialiste
elle a dû animer une rubrique entière
juste sur la foi de de son goût pour le
bio de beaucoup de gens y vont traiter
les cas des sciences et l'étude
scientifique comme ils traiteraient
n'importe quel autre sujet qui vont
considérer que la parole d'un chercheur
et une opinion alors qu'il peut être
qu'il parle au nom d'un
l'un collectif qui parle il essaye
d'être au plus près de sa discipline et
du consensus
les chercheurs ou peut-être ils ne
parlent qu'en son nom propre
quand on a l'habitude en étant
généraliste de considérer qu' il faut
donner la parole à tout le monde il faut
donner la parole à quelqu'un qui est du
parti communiste quelqu'un qui est
centriste quelqu'un qui est du partage
du ps quelques inquiétudes de tout
donner la parole un petit peu à tout le
monde et là on lorsque quelqu'un arrive
avec une milliers divergentes en
sciences on se dit il faut lui donner la
parole mais alors que ça marche pas
comme ça le journalisme scientifique de
l'emprunt obsar journalisme de
vulgarisation euros
un journalisme qui touche à la
vérification des annonces est donc une
sorte de journalisme type fact checking
c'est pas ça qu'on doit faire on doit
quoi est ce que les personnes qui nous
parlent parlent ou est-ce qu'elle bosse
et se positionne par rapport à la au
collectif scientifique dans l'idée que
la science un travail cumulatif
collectif et correctifs ce que qui se
place en marge
ce travail cumulatif collectif et
correctifs ce qu'il s'insère de danse
qui s'insère harmonieusement dedans
est-ce qu'ils sont pas à l'aise dedans
et c'est ça qui est intéressant mais si
on s'est pas posé ces questions sur
c'est quoi déjà le l'édification du nom
d'un savoir 10 scientifiques se planque
et quand on se demande pas comment est
ce qu'on produit une étude si on se
demande pas ce que c'est qu'une étude
est ce que sont les différents types
d'études n'est pas mon fait le
journalisme acquis et qui a été l'objet
de mes critiques dans mon travail depuis
à peu près six ans ouais je reviens mais
après des études en journalisme
scientifique qu'est ce que t'as gel
alors pendant mes études j'ai eu la
chance de faire de mettre les deux pieds
dont la médiation scientifique entre la
vue d'un assaut qui s'appelait
l'association icare à paris donc je
faisais d'être des ateliers après
l'école pour les enfants
ils faisaient que la vulgarisation très
classique quoi
des ateliers de découverte des sciences
de curiosité bon voilà ça va ça me
plaisait énormément
et puis j'ai commencé à me poser des
questions justement est-ce que les les
notions que je vous lis la river
là je vais vulgarise bien est-ce que je
n'avais pas l'impression quand on fait
tomber des objets par exemple pour
essayer de faire sentir aux gens aux
enfants que les corps c'est pas parce
qu'on est plus lourd qu'on tombe plus
vite on se retrouve à dire des choses
qui sont pas tout à fait vrai voire même
qui sont carrément fausses ont commis à
la friction de l'air alors on va il ya
des expériences qu'on peut pas mener on
va mais on va compenser à dire voilà les
voyez bien que les corps tombent à la
même vitesse
c'est travail à la friction de l'air
donc c'est dont les concepts que tu
balances battu lui des choses fausses
c'est parfois dans les représentations
des enfants si je m'apercevais qualité
les choses qui comprenait pas ce qui m'a
intéressé beaucoup dans ce qu'en ce
moment là c'était pourquoi les enfants
compagnie les choses qui me semblent
évidentes
qu'est-ce qui les bloque et parfois ce
qui est bloqué ces acquis il est un
évidement c'est que il avait une
représentation préalable du monde qu'ils
étaient légitimes et tu m'as j'essayais
de le plaquer les concepts qui moi me
semblait légitime et saab cédée
donc c'est quelque chose qui m'a
beaucoup intéressé et j'ai continué
plutôt que de commencer tout de suite
une carrière devant la liste anti
fixèrent de la médiation en présentiel
avec avec des gens juste après juste
après mes études j'ai gagné un concours
de vidéastes je faisais beaucoup
beaucoup de vidéos du fait de la
formation audiovisuelle et donc je suis
parti au québec on faisait un tour de
tour du pays pour faire des reportages
un reportage par semaine pour n'est
monté enfin voilà tout devait être
produit ça devait passer sur télé québec
etc
et il est sam ça a été très très
éprouvant de faire d'être complètement
isolé et de produire seuls les enquêtes
que je voulais forcément original que je
voulais forcément pertinente voulez et
faire ça tout seul c'était vraiment je
suis rentré en france un peu lessivé
c'était en 2007 donc je suis et ce que
j'ai vraiment envie de faire de faire de
la vidéo de faire de la vulgarisation de
faire les enquêtes de terrain et j'ai
rencontré un homme qui travaillait dans
une cabine et de consultants et qui m'a
proposé de faire des antes de faire des
enquêtes journalistiques en parallèle de
ces enquêtes sociologiques
il bossait dans des pourparlers xemple
la sncf la sncf qui bossait pour la sncf
il veut ni une enquête sociologique dont
la question la question posée c'était
pourquoi est-ce que plus on met de
l'argent et les trains soient propres
plus les gens considèrent que les trains
sont sales et lui met une enquête
sociologique là dessus mais moi j'ai un
regard de sociologue et j'aimerais bien
que tu viennes une enquête
journalistique
là dessus il avait vu les vidéos que les
produits au québec et donc j'ai fait des
enquêtes en interne dans les skis
m'intéressait c'était encore une fois le
conflit de représentation entre on va
dire là les usagers et les cultures
d'entreprise entre dans les entreprises
les cultures les différents métiers et
j'adorais ça j'adorais le travail de
réflexion sur les cultures et une la
crise de 2008 donc lui il allait plus de
fonds pour pour mener son projet très
innovant de faire des enquêtes
journalistiques et donc ça a été un peu
la diège quoi professionnellement vu que
j'avais envie de continuer là dedans
j'ai monté un projet pour faire un
reportage
une enquête en russie où je suis parti
en russie sur mes propres fonds en
parallèle ce qui me finançait c'était la
médiation scientifique les ateliers et
je faisais des pirates à gauche mais bon
j'avais des grands projets mais s'était
jamais à satisfaisant
je travaille pas pour les rédactions sur
le long cours j'allais je vends anglais
un article je vendais une collaboration
à un blog me donner un peu d'argent mais
c'était un peu précaire il puis pour un
remplacement va proposer de travailler
au magazine de la santé par un site web
du magazine de la santé pour une semaine
d'une alain qui se répétaient là le
jeunot je me suis dit on va là tu veux
travailler pour la remplacer une semaine
le temps qu'elle soit 160 me mets moi
pendant les études je m'étais toujours
dit tous les sujets que j'avais prêté un
des sujets très très probablement jamais
c'est les questions de sciences santé
défunt santé et laissez-nous son
téléfilm pour moi ça m'intéressait pas
je m'intéressais à ces grandes gestions
ésotérique dont parlait tout à l'heure
mais bon que j'ai un peu mis de côté qui
j'allais les choses qui me plaisait
beaucoup plus l'astronomie me plaisait
beaucoup plus d'un des questions qui
touchent à l'est les problématiques
autour de de l'écologie dû développement
économique les questions autour des
ressources en eau des choses qui vont
être qu'ils vont encore bien avec la
géologie qui vont être en lien avec les
écosystèmes à ça ça m'intéressait
vraiment mais alors je m'étais toujours
dit sincèrement si tu as besoin de te
poses des questions médicales et sur ta
santé as-tu demande à tous mes sens afin
qu'un journaliste qu'est ce qu'il va
faire et on y croit un médecin et un jeu
ça me semblait pas être un vrai mais
c'est quoi c'est encore un gros préjugés
et très vite très très vite pas que chez
les collègues mais dans le en lisant les
articles autour de la santé et de la
médecine
j'ai aperçu qu'avec des choses qui ne
nous semblait fausse en ayant brassé
beaucoup de choses
arthur hésité par le passé les choses
ont semblé un peu contradictoire
il avait tout ce travail que scepticisme
scientifique thérèse et éthique où je
m'étais frotté aux questions sur
l'homéopathie sur les pratiques qui me
semblait relever le pseudo médecine de
choses il ya les paillettes et réalités
que je voyais traité sans aucun recul
sans aucun esprit critique permet à
forcément les confrères du magazine mais
par les confrères du journal si l'hélico
et puis des choses plus anodines plus
anodines la façon dont vous voyez que
les agences de presse par les deux des
sujets que je connaissais gérer accem à
des grandes chaque jour les agences de
presse qui nombre d'articles sur la
géologie sûr il tient le chic leur accès
à ces ressources sont diffusées en
cadence et joyeux sais pas si c'est vrai
pas aussi rigoureux que way est donc
gagnant dans cette
dans ce flux d'informations pour une
fois j'étais pas juste producteur jj
stage wyeth ces flux de données à très
rigoureux est ce qu elles sont quatre et
rigoureux parce que je suis nulle grèce
qu'elles sont pas très rigoureux parce
que je suis parce que c'est pas
rigoureux et puis à des choses qui m'ont
sauté aux yeux au travers des questions
sur les études scientifiques en
m'intéressant à les questions appelait
au terry sur deux les études sur le en
parapsychologie des études sur la
télépathie des choses comme ça que
j'avais eu l'occasion de lire j'avais vu
que la ville est une façon de faire une
étude catherine mille et une façons de
concevoir ton des échantillons à la base
pour biaiser t voilà le cri compris que
c'était facile de faire des sacs pour i
et ii et de faire des études on avait
déjà la conclusion avant de les mener de
triturer été donné et je m'aperçois que
cet effet en médecine je continue à une
nouvelle étude qui est sorti j'avais
envie d'aller voir comment elle a été
fait avait cette culture de est ce que
les études peuvent être mal fait qui me
donnait envie de jeu parti du principe
comme tous mes confrères que puisque
tout le monde en parlait c'est que
c'étaient de belles études mais j'avais
envie de voir à quel point c'était des
belges études à quel point elle était
bien faite et qui va je m'apercevais
rang en allant à la source de suivi de
ces études que certaines qui était très
médiatisé ressembler beaucoup mes études
bullshit que
kim avait qui m'avait fait réfléchir sur
les écueils de la parapsychologie
commencé à faire des critiques c'est
qu'on ne devrait pas de couvrir ces
choses des choses là dans nos rédactions
avec d'autres copains qui avaient
inquiété dans d'autres médias qui
parlent de santé aujourd'hui mais c'est
un peu le problématique qu'on parle de
ces études de mauvaise qualité et qu'on
nous laisse pas forcément le temps de
deux les de les déconstruire et je me
sentais un peu isolée sur ces questions
heureusement j'avais une rédactrice en
chef qui était savez beaucoup
d'ouverture d'esprit qui m'a laissé la
bride sur le cou et qui m'a dit
effectivement de façon on est dans un
système très concurrentiel on vient
énormément de médias qui parlent de
santé et qu'ils reprennent les mêmes
infos est basiquement se partage
si l' agence france-presse 10 voilà
aujourd'hui il ya une étude publiée dans
nature qui montre qu' il ya un
médicament un outil efficace voilà sur
telle maladie tout le monde va reprendre
l'info s'il ya des médias qui reprennent
l'info qu'ils ont la même exposition
médiatique on se partagent le gâteau du
clic le nombre de clics des internautes
par dix mais c'est pour ça qu'il faut
être dessus parce que c'est dommage le
10 et le gâteau par neuf et que toi tu
lui tu récupères pas quelques minutes
donc autant le diviser par dix un peu la
logique qui était derrière mais elle
avait une réflexion à partager la même
réflexion
le dira pas laissons les se partager le
gâteau en neuf études on arrive après
avec un regard un peu plus critique
peut-être qu'on dira la même chose mais
dès qu'on va dire des choses un peu
divergentes
et puis on va arriver à un moment un
temps différent on sera les seuls à
limay de cette critique
elle sera plus constructives et les gens
qui vont repasser sur cette info la
ronde irakien en fait c'est plus
compliqué si ça les avait intéressés ils
ont un complément d'information qui va
peut-être remettre très fortement
perspective qui a été dit donc on a dix
jours
une autre temporalité quoi et ça m'a
permis de faire mon travail beaucoup
plus correctement alors peut-être qu'on
n'était pas les seuls mais en fait on
travaille dans un service d'actualités
avec une logique un tout petit peu plus
magazine 1-1 mensuellement en théorie là
le temps de travailler sur les sur
l'actif en prenant 1 ça veut pas dire
que parce que tu as l'opportunité de le
faire que tu le fais vraiment ce qu'il
ya plein d'autres raisons de de torchon
articles de leurs chais de le bâclé et
tout simplement de l'écrire en partant
de ce que tu penses être vrai et pas en
menant pas une vraie enquête et en fait
on a une il ya des préjugés aussi que
quand tu fais de la vulgarisation ou du
travail sur l'actu n'a pas vraiment dans
cette affaire puisque tours seul rôle
serait de tendre le micro à ceux qui
font l'actu ou à vulgariser ce que tout
le monde sait déjà
finalement tu meures et ne faire que
répéter sans fin ce qui est déjà
disponible
si tu veux faire un article sur pourquoi
est-ce qu'on attrape froid par exemple
bas sur guy tu tapes sur internet
pourquoi est-ce qu'on attrape froid tu
regardes les trois premiers trucs tu
vois que tout le monde dit la même chose
on attrape froid parce que la clim parce
que le froid a fait vite et des forces
militaires qui se trouvent et qui tue le
formule différemment et voilà tu es
vulgarisateur quoi qui dans le monde de
la médiation scientifique avec tout le
monde faisait ça et moi ça me plaisait
pas et je voyais que justement quand je
me disais mais comment est-ce qu'on sait
ce qu'on sait du liant savoir qui est le
premier à avoir 10 1
ces pigments sur le coup du comment
attraper froid un jour dia tient faire
au lieu de faire un article d'actu fait
un article pour l'encyclopédie du site
pourquoi est-ce qu'on attrape froid et
puis tu vas voir c'est rapide
on va faire comme tout le monde quoi et
en utilisant la petite méthode curio
logique de on va vérifier qui a dit ça
en premier et pourquoi
pourquoi est ce qu'ils croient ce qu'ils
croient qu est ce qu il a tout mis en
oeuvre pour essayer de se donner tort
enfin ce qu'il a eu une pensée
scientifique on affirmer ça qui est le
premier à avoir confirmé ont attrapé au
cou et que nous que nos voix et rien
n'était eh ben ça m'a pris trois mois à
apprendre toutes les études que je
pouvais trouver les références aux
études vérifier les références de ses
références
regardez les protocoles qui avaient été
menées et c'est un travail de dingue au
coi de de remonter là j'avais rencontré
des gens qui me disaient ce que j'allais
trouver mais il savait pas trop où il
avait entendu il avait en eau tout le
monde avait une opinion avec une opinion
tout le monde était sûr de son coup
et donc j'ai fait un gros boulot alors
qu'il était pas mal payés après parce
que je les mets en ligne qui est près
des gens apprennent tout le monde sait
bien que en fait ça marche pas comme ça
mais dans tout le monde sait pas bien et
donc en fait mais même quand enquête sur
les idées reçues même quand tu
vulgariser auprès d'un public des
notions vérifier quelle que ce que tu
veuilles ariz
bah c'est pas qu'une idée reçue et qu'il
ya un vrai travail de décorticage bas
est ce qu on a tout mis en oeuvre
est-ce que les expériences et leçons de
bonne qualité est ce que quand tu dis
voilà c'est parce que c'est parce que
les virus sont plus que la coque qui
protège les virus la coke lipidique qui
protège les virus bas-fonds à une
certaine température et que quand il
fait froid va elle est plus résistante
et qu' est-ce que c'est à l'état
d'hypothèse
est ce que cette affirmation elle a été
étayée par plusieurs études par
plusieurs laboratoires est ce que ça
marche que pour certains types de virus
donc quand tu commences à aller dans le
détail tu mets pas mal de conditionnel
et quand tu veux le yari aux jantes et
c'est de voir quels sont leurs besoins
de compréhension est-ce que ce que tu
vas leur dire une fois qu'ils vont être
ils vont leur verbaliser ils vont pas
colporter des idées fausses que ça
demande un travail très long
ça aussi mais il ya des gens qui ce
qu'ils se saisissent de cinq et dix mois
c'est bon on a compris on le remet sur
le seul marché du savoir et on va encore
distordre l'information donc j'ai
rencontré plein de collègues qui avaient
cette méthode cette approche j'en ai
rencontré beaucoup plus qu'ils n'avaient
pas du tout du tout du tout cette
méthode
et ça m'a posé beaucoup de questions et
c'est un peu le fond de tout mon travail
critique du journalisme depuis depuis un
certain nombre d'années quoi est-ce que
tu joues quentin quant à lui écrit cette
histoire sur pourquoi ce qu'on attrape
fois d'ailleurs est-ce que c'est trop
compliqué pour expliquer maintenant ou
sais pas c'est pas très compliqué mais
en gros il ya plusieurs hypothèses
déjà à partir du moment où il ya une
histoire de pourquoi est ce qu'on pense
qu'on attrape froid parce
qu'effectivement il ya une corrélation
sur des maladies qui apparaissent
cycliquement mais une fois qu'on a
découvert que les maladies de tes liées
à des violations des risques de la
grippe qui allait les rhinovirus qu'il y
avait les coronavirus qui avait tout ça
bon on a commencé à se dire c'est plus
probablement les virus qui tue et les
bactéries etc qui causent les maladies
qu'est ce que le froid le voit là dedans
on froid est-ce que les deux hypothèses
affaiblir le système immunitaire
favorisé la dispersion des virus sont
favoris et favorisé la survie des virus
en fait c'est compliqué c'est qu'il faut
on peut faire ça au cas par cas info tu
va enquêter sur escaut on a fait des
études pour vérifier que ton système
immunitaire était plus faible en
présence du rhinovirus
enfin et comme on le fait en tulle à
mettre des gens dans des bassines d'eau
froide pendant trois heures et après tu
vas leur inoculer notamment le
rhinovirus
et puis tu vas voir si tu as une plus
grande proportion de gens qui disent
qu'ils restent qui tombe malade qu'il ya
des gens qui ont été ils sont restés au
chaud dans sa part fois que tous les
virus ont attesté on
à tester tous les russes dangereux il ya
questions éthiques mais tous les virus
sont à tester ça marche pas on m'a fait
des tests avec des allergiques qu'on
exposés d'abord des allergènes qui sait
bien les muqueuses irrité et donc en
fait on a éliminé la vraisemblance de
ses hypothèses pour beaucoup de virus
pour beaucoup de l'exposition l'art n'a
pas prouvé que c'était faux
universellement pour tolérer ce n'est en
tout cas que pour tout ce qu'on a testé
cette question d'affaiblir le système
immunitaire de façon transitoire ou
d'affaiblir les muqueuses d'affaiblir
les voies respiratoires ça marche ça
tient pas vraiment la route contre si ça
joue un rôle il est extrêmement
marginale tu peux pas le détecter
alors après donc y avait la survie dents
dans les milieux et là ça semble assez
crédible pour un certain nombre de virus
sont des structures effectivement euros
tu te représenter ça comme un virus
ils sont en permanence en train de faire
de l'autostop quoi et ils attendent que
toi tu toi véhicules tunés j'ai vu les
prêts là bas si les uv les l'aise si si
les uv les détruisent si tout ce qui va
permettre de garder dans l'intégrité
mais pas là où où se dégrade très
rapidement tu vas devoir être un peu de
chance d'être exposé en fait c'est la
prob à un concours ainsi plus plus ils
ont de chances de survivre si longtemps
de chance d'être à hauteur d'homme tous
les questions de dispersion dans l'air
avec les températures avec les les
histoires autour des de la ventilation
voilà là plein de simulation avec
différents modes et des modèles réels
des expériences de terrain et différents
types de virus et donc tout à trac c'est
s'est passé plus des choses mécanique et
la biologie du virus sont alors à dire
dieu mais voilà tu valides et quoi
qu'ils rentrent en jeu mer pour le
détail g on va sur mon blog un article
c'est le cold case voilà où je
où j'essaye de voir si cette affaire est
vraiment classe et et 6
est ce que on n'a pas trop vite accusé
le froid donc ça c'est sûr mais ce qu'on
n'a pas trop vite accusé le système
immunitaire d'être fragilisée c'est un
mode un peu enquête policière
il ya plein de choses sur le même modèle
enquêter sur est ce que le stress
augmente le risque de cancer
voilà j'étais partie de mon idée reçue
et oui évidemment je maîtrise avec pas
très long les ressources et les fils à
papa est très long mais je savais bien
de la force de râler auprès de mes
confrères il faut pas partir de ton idée
reçue il faut la voir dans un coin de ma
tête ça peut servir de point de dialogue
de discours d'akreuch pour ton article
il faut revenir à zéro la question c'est
aujourd'hui il semble qu'on le sache
mais depuis quand on sait comment est
remonté la généalogie de cette idée et
toutes les nuances il faut apporter
c'est quoi les médiateurs du stress
c'est quoi les molécules
qu'est ce que c'est que le stresse tiens
d'ailleurs c'est une question depuis
c'est quoi les molécules qui sont
largués et en quoi elles interagissent
je me suis dit est ce que c'est le bon
niveau de questions est-ce qu'il faut
parvenir à la à la question encore plus
priorité c est ce qu'on a vraiment
observé ça avant de chercher pourquoi s
comment font les licornes pour traverser
les murs terrific les lycans traversent
les murs voir vérifier qu'il ya des
licornes quoi et c'est dans le monde de
l'esprit critique cette image de la
bande hors de fontenelle de fontenelle
c'est cette histoire qui était raconté
qu'ils étaient colportées par deux de
nombreux auteurs comme quoi un enfant ne
tenir avec une bague en or et beaucoup
ici d'interpréter sur comment est-ce que
ça puisse produire
comment physiologiquement on peut voir
de l'or est et pourquoi les dieux ont
autorisé ont créé cet événement est ce
que c'était un symbole et jusqu'à attend
que quelqu'un se pose la question mais
est ce que c'est vraiment arrivé est ce
que parce que cette dent en or existe
oui est ce que c'est une bande heures
annoncées juste une dent qu'elle était
plaquée imposteur il aurait fait se
poser la question avant de se demander
comment se demander est ce que est ce
que ça a vraiment eu lieu est ce qu'on a
vraiment constaté que les gens qui
avaient subi un stress important en
plein deuil des choses comme ça
avait plus de cancers et est-ce que
c'est pas juste une corrélation bêtes
par exemple les gens qui ont un cancer
diagnostic vers 50 ans parce que avec le
taux de reproduction des cellules la
probabilité que une reproduction de
cellules qui déconne le nombre d'années
que tu subis depuis nombre d'années que
pas mal de choses qui sont ou même voilà
le stress va être lié à une forte
consommation klopp un plein de raisons
comme ça
est-ce que ça serait juste une
corrélation ou est-ce qu'on a isolé ses
paramètres là et identifié autre chose
et en fait je me suis aperçu que il y
avait des gens qui s'était posé la
question avant avec des artistes avaient
pas été forcément très bien ficelé et où
très bien médiatisée avec beaucoup de
gens avaient plusieurs fois refait ses
expérimentations qu'est ce que ça leur
pose des questions et que beaucoup
arrivé à la conclusion que que c'était
pas si franc que ça et qu il y avait des
gens qui étaient en deuil et qui avaient
eu un cancer avant et des gens qui
avaient une quête en deuil qui avait un
cancer après quoi se monter plus à une
question d'âge la question c'est est-ce
que le cancer cause de deuil wasquehal
bay cause de cancer ou est-ce que ça
[ __ ] de rien à voir et puis ben géant
là encore passer plusieurs mois
épluchez les littératures qui je voyais
que dans des revues savantes je sais pas
tu vas sur le site de l'association de
la recherche sur le cancer et 10 non non
ça c'est ça c'est du bullshit ça c'est
faux et on sait que c'est vrai je suis
quand même quand même dans les films par
exemple le film de lelouch l' homme
femme mode d'emploi c'est peut-être le
le coeur de l'histoire et avec un
haut-lieu annonce qu'il a un cancer
alors que c'est pas vrai et le stress
que ça lui procure fait que ça une sorte
d' effet nocebo qui génère le contient
donc donc ben ouais mais c'est car si
une fille qu'on et puis et puis et puis
mais tout le monde dit ça et puis quand
même des des gens des thérapeutes qui
nous disent qu élément à temps c'était
un petit sortent d'où ça les gens qui
disent les maladies c'est parce que
parce que parce que ben vous êtes
stressé que vous générez vos maladies et
comment est ce qu'ils ont
et fier ça avant que tu veux pas me
lisez les gens je considérais pas que ce
qu'ils faisaient c'était là la médecine
mais je me disais que rice heures sur un
truc qui est pas tout à fait faux ils
exagèrent
il ya des sectes qui grossissent le 13
sur cette histoire de les coupler cancer
c'est de votre faute les fautes de vos
ancêtres par là je dis c'est de la
connerie mais voilà il se caricature et
tire profit de quelque chose qu'il ya
peut-être un embryon de vérité ou de oud
accroche dans le réel et biba pareille
enquête longue
sur quelles études ont identifié ça et
avec des arguments pour quelles études
avaient les arguments contre comment
elles ont été faites à ce qu'elles ont
été critiquées et puis ben conclusion il
n'ya pas de lien enfin y'a pas de bien
il ya une corrélation n'est absolument
pas de lien de cause à effet et voilà
qu'il va prix tu va réfléchir à comment
vulgariser ça et qui commandent
vulgariser ça sans créer de rejet sans
créer de 1 et fait boomerang ou de gens
qui ont qui ont besoin de donner du sens
à leur maladie
et là on revient encore une fois sur
cette partie de ma formation qui était
de communication interculturelle de
considérer qu'il est trop malade c'est
presque une culture en soi et que être
médecin c'est aussi une culture ans avec
les médecins parfois communiquer avec
leurs patients d'une façon qui va créer
des fausses représentations et donc
c'est mon travail de journaliste de
vulgarisation des rencontres celui du
journaliste de vérification qui va être
comment tu parles des choses et je sais
que plein de fois j'ai les critiques les
retours sur mes articles des choses
étonnantes quoi là on parle de deux
d'idées reçues mais je me suis beaucoup
penchés sur des des hawks des rumeurs
one semblé problématique pendant la la
la résurgence des ball a mis fin il ya
trois quatre ans là il y avait une
rumeur qui circulait sur des pratiques
en naturopathie qui permettent de
traiter ebola traité bola avec le
chlorure de magnésium si je me souviens
bien
l'un d'eux de choses sur facebook qui
circulaient comme quoi des perses du
personnel de deux médecins sans
frontières ou non de la croix-rouge à
vérifier là je dis ça de tête avec les
écureuils de magnésium pour traiter des
malades des mollahs et que ça avait
fonctionné que c'est pas la première
fois qu'on utilise sa part encore une
fois affirmation étonnante
enthousiasmante et et si c'est vrai
c'est trop cool si une fois que ça
arrive il faut opposer un niveau de
vérification aussi important plutôt
enthousiaste plus ou plus et si c'est
vrai c'est cool plus il faut en face
être vigilants et prudents j'ai toujours
pas j'ai tendance à dire que la science
est le juste équilibre entre
enthousiasme et prudence plus tout
bascule d'un côté plus il faut compenser
de l'autre est un funambule que tu sois
scientifico milliards isat heures
adressant c'est la même problématique
est donc je suis allé vérifier
l'historique de cette idée là évidemment
je suis allé voir je me suis renseigné
auprès de de lagence nos gouvernementale
en question est ce que cette histoire
avait mené un ancrage quelconque en réel
est ce qu'ils admettez que ça avait eu
lieu
qui étaient les témoins qu'il avait
colporté bon évidemment c'est un tissu
d'âneries a évidemment c'est peut-être
pas évident d'ailleurs à dire évidemment
c'est pas vrai mais en fait vu ce que
j'ai dit avant on pouvait se douter que
j'allais à la fin de mon histoire allait
être celle ci j'en suis arrivée et même
en suspens dans mon jugement pendant le
temps l enquête
et bien j'en suis arrivé à ce qu'on
pouvait craindre c'est que tout ça a été
une
une rumeur bien bien pourri et que qui
avait évidemment le chlorure de
magnésium n'a jamais fait ses preuves
pour traiter aucune maladie grave voilà
donc je ferai un article essaye de se
structurer en en utilisant ce que je
sais des réseaux qui colportent ces
informations en essayant de ne pas dire
de penser comme et d'être lus par les
gens qui le dirigeant qui considère que
c'est une connerie je m'en fous d'être
ligue 2 les gens qui ont jamais entendu
parler de ça il faut que je fasse gaffe
la façon de ce jeu de je vais pardon la
façon dont je vais structurer mon
article pour que ils partent pas avec
plus de questionnements en que de
réponses
si tu exposes les gens aient une idée
qui n'avaient pas tu leur dis il ya des
faits trucks ouais non il y avait un
autre nom pour ça j'ai malheureusement
gelé les parents tête par la spécialité
c'est d'interviewer les gens après
qu'ils aient passé une mauvaise nuit de
sommeil le contexte vous passez
l'interview c'est un peu ce cas là donc
je ne retrouve pas le nom de l'effet
mais il ya un petit fascicule qui a été
fait par deux chercheurs qui résume
leurs travaux et accueillent leurs
travaux mais le leurs champs
disciplinaires qui a été traduit en
français selon de précis de réfutation
qui interroge la façon de comment est-ce
que tu vulgarise une une une contre
expertise et une contrat si tu as fait
une contre enquête ou une enquête quand
tu veux des bénitiers quelque chose qui
veut des construire une idée reçue ou
une idée comment est-ce que tu présentes
les choses pour que les gens retiennent
ce que tu vaux qui reviennent et ils ont
fait des expériences de psychologie où
tu exposes les gens à d'abord à l'idée
fausse alors dix ans les ovnis à ce
compte il atterrit dans la ville de
saint calais et étudiants suis dit non
ou que tu écris ton article en disant
non les ovnis n'ont pas atterri à saint
calais petit tu continues est ce que
c'est ça aura le même effet le stuart ci
écrit l'article
certaines personnes pensent que des
ovnis sont ont été ré à saint calais
mais un petit point ou est-ce que tu
inverse
les sceptiques de l'atterrissage ils ont
posé plein de questions autour de ça est
ce que ceux qui n'en avaient jamais
entendu parler qu'est ce que ça va comme
et très doux
la conclusions de leurs travaux c'est
que il faut commencer par le nom il faut
commencer par dire l'âge on va vous
parler de quelque chose de faux il faut
dire tout de suite
attention on va bâtir du bullshit en
vous expliquant que que nous on en est
arrivé à la conclusion que c'est un
bolide que on peut avoir des raisons
très bonne de dit croire et juste
prévenir que la conclusion de durer si
c'est sa première chose parce que les
gens vont peut-être pas aller jusqu'au
bout de l'article donc pas lui mais
simplement parce que dans leur façon
dont ils ont structuré l'info dans leur
tête ils vont le ranger dans la case as
et un savoir sur quelque chose que des
gens pensent être vrai mais c'est peut
être plus compliqué tête ils vont être
happé par le fait que la façon dont
formule la chose typiquement tu vas là
dans mon article cold case is la ccal
caisse de points non là le le froid ne
cause pas le rhume mais alors pourquoi
j'ai choisi ce titre qui est très
mauvais pour le référencement
j'aurais pu mettre le référencement le
froid provoque-t-il de rhume
la dérogation bien parce que parce qu'il
ya ces travaux qui disent il faut que
dans ton titre et que des langages on
dise comment c'est vraiment une
conclusion c'est presque par la
conclusion quoi et équipe est
essentielle
excellent travail donc je reviens à mon
histoire de deggo la dre g11 troisième
diamant dit qu'en 3e dan en digressions
donc pour vous il est donc bon j'essaye
de penser à tout ça et je fais l'article
et parce que le sujet avait été sa
demande est vraiment d'une petit boulot
quoi et que ben mahi hérarchie aller
bah dit de le faire qu'on m'avait donné
des contacts qui était chiant à trouver
auprès j'avais fait tout l'anc est tout
seul comme un grand mais je sais pas ça
me semblait bien de ne pas dire ne pas
faire mon ne pas mettre mon ego avant et
puis dire voilà c'est le travail d'une
rédaction qui laisse un journaliste
faire ce boulot et j'ai signé cet
article la rédaction du pire on en
signant une fille quand même c'est vrai
que fit au boulot mais mais chez pas
c'est suffisamment rare de laisser un
journaliste faire ce type de boulot sur
une rumeur de faire du du fact checking
de rumeurs facebook ont mené vent de
m'autoriser à créer le propos la
première rubrique de fact checking
scientifique dédié sur un média grand
public j'avais écrit un truc qui
s'applique du faux ou de l'info c'était
ma rubrique et les rumeurs autour des 1
2 des sciences bas c'est moi qui les
tanks et et on avait une rubrique de fac
ni scientifique dans un média
scientifique c'est ça n'existait pas en
tout cas dans le monde francophone
après par la suite il ya eu des choses
comme le détecteur de rumeurs chez
l'agencé science presse etc
mais voilà encore une fois je voulais
dire merci je signe la rédaction quelles
ont été les réactions sur les réseaux
sociaux de cet article peut des donkey
méthodique historique terme était en les
seuls commentaires
il y en a eu pas mal maëlys les seuls
retour du détective l'argent qu'on dira
c'est cool ça me fait réfléchir mais les
solutions on n'a pas eu merci on a pas
eu
on s'en fout on n'y croyait pas déjà non
il ya un la rédaction vous vous êtes mis
à beaucoup pour essayer pour écrire cet
article
et ben si vous êtes mis à beaucoup c'est
probablement parce que vous ayez
beaucoup d'énergie pour essayer de nous
faire croire que que c'est faux c'est
donc probablement que c'est vrai le
raisonnement très complotistes et si
pour une fois la rédaction se met sur un
dossier c'est qu'elle a envie de nous de
faire taire la fosse et pas juste un
journaliste mais une inquiétude
rédaction qui mène une enquête et que
c'est pas habituel c'est habituel donc
c'est louche
je n'avais pas anticipé ça là j'avoue je
n'avais pas anticipé que la presse et on
va dire en fait pas que les gens
cherchent et une rixe et puis la
rationalisation et c'est peut-être de la
régionalisation a posteriori mais
néanmoins l'article est tombé à côté de
sa cible j'ai les moyens que j'ai
vérifié nous de mesurer les impacts qui
est très faible quand tu fais des blogs
coin de fumée le moment que les gens tu
écrivais me disant voilà jeux
l'utilisant tel cadre sur celui-là je me
suis planté et de voir que les seules
ressources et des retours qui qui
rationalisent à possible voilà ça m'a
récemment interroge aris tout ça ça
c'est différent ce qu'on nourrit mon
qu'est-ce que tu auras fait différemment
j'aurais en fait avec le recul et puis
en faisant d'autres articles me suis
aperçu que il faut beaucoup moins
détaillé les raisons que tu as de
conclure que c'est faux ça que si ton
enquête
quand tu mènes une enquête
journalistique quelles qu'elles soient
tus et tabitha un faisceau de
présomptions et à plein de petits faits
qui pointe dans une direction d'un autre
fait qui pointe un peu dans l'autre et
puis basta défaite décisive tas d'effets
secondaires mais qui toi dans ta
construction mentale ton était vraiment
vraiment décisif dans ton raisonnement
mais qui sont pas convaincants pour
établir tu peux être un peu comme dans
un procès quoi l'avocat il va dire voilà
il quand même pas mal de raisons de
penser à la fin il pose la grosse preuve
en fait ce que j'aurais fait
différemment ces jeunes israël est
beaucoup plus à l'économie tout faire un
gros dossier sur l'histoire de cette
idée fausse ce rallye sur un les gens
affirment que c'est faux 2 c'est une
idée qui existe depuis très longtemps et
qui à chaque fois ont été réfutées et si
vous voulez en savoir plus allez voir
ailleurs aller voir ailleurs parce qu'en
fait je vous mettre à disposition tout
mon travail mais
basiquement en fait très rapidement nous
explique que c'est faux qu'on a des
raisons de ces variations ne pas les
détails et autant que ça sauf au ce qui
à ceux qui veulent en savoir plus et que
dans la représentation d'une bonne
partie du public sur la façon dont le
travail de le savoir et vulgarisée par
les journalistes ont vu des risées sur
internet et vulgariser sur des blogs ils
s'attendent en fait à ce que les choses
se régulariser à l'essentiel soit
vulgarisé simplement et est pas tombé
sur une thèse de 10 réfute quoi et en
fait il faut penser aux attentes de ces
gens-là dochia liées à l'économie
faire un article moi je sais pourquoi
est ce que j'affirmais est vrai ça va
être très frustrant et je peux être
donnée un peu moins de sources pendant
l'exposé je les ai données accessibles
je vais consacrer plus de temps et
éventuellement à dialoguer avec le
public à dialoguer dans la section
commentaire à dialoguer sur facebook
avec les gens mais voilà aller plus à
l'essentiel et en fait c'est ce que j'ai
fait une impression dans ce blog j'ai
fait pas mal d'articles après sur le
site où je faisais un article obélie
c'est assez logique la piscine avait
envie de faire un complément pour les
gens qui nous attend là il raconte des
conneries
et si vous voulez en savoir plus et
dialoguer avec cet auteur qui
probablement un connard vendu à je ne
sais quel lobby qui est le lobby du il
pense pas comme vous il a un blog aller
sur son blog puis vous allez voir il
détaille et j'ai rarement eu des gens
qui me sont tombés dessus sur le blog
parce qu'ils sont en fait c'était un
truc ont de quoi ils y voient un petit
article sur un média mainstream à 3 le
direct dax un média grand public aux
médias qu apparemment généraliste qui
affirme un truc si leur semble être un
peu un petit peu de poil à gratter et
qu'ils disent
et en plus si vous voulez en savoir plus
et pousser les arguments bah allez voir
ils disent il a probablement pas
d'arguments quoi et puis voit que il a
des arguments
puis en a qui me dit moi je suis pas
d'apparaître vos arguments voilà je il
me semble que ce que vous avancez c'est
un peu faible que votre étude pourquoi
c'était une des leurs
vous dites qu'elle est vrai des études
fausse damas hama manoury dans ma
réflexion il faut que j'ai aussi que
dans la plupart de mes articles je
pointe vers des ressources critiques sur
c'est quoi un article pourquoi est ce
qu'il ya des faux positifs
un peu de vulgarisation des stats qui
était un mais grand dada à la fac aussi
et donc j'ai accompagné mon blog de
ressources sur ces questions et ça s'est
toujours très bien passé quoi et même
mes interventions télé quand il y avait
des gens qui étaient pas d'accord je
leur dis là écoutez ce les questions que
vous posez sur le site poser aussi en
fait vous croyez que j'ai des a priori
négatifs est en fait déjà dire gédé a
posteriori négatif alors là je parle je
sais qui je parle et je sais que dans le
monde qui est le tien le mot a priori
n'a pas le même sens dans le don le
grand public quand on fait des
raisonnements bayésiens le sens du mot a
priori pas forcément celui qui est
partagé par tout le monde quand on dit
j'ai des a priori moi je parle vraiment
dans l'emploi dans le sens auquel mon
voisin qui s'est jamais intéressé à aux
sciences hommage au sol parle c'est
ouais t'as des prix jugés tu sais pas
trop d'où ils viennent et tu sais même
pas si c'est si l'emploi même pas en
termes de de vraisemblance quoique c'est
juste que tu souhaites tu as été élevé
dans une famille de dragon c'est ça les
a priori qui va être un peu dans ce sens
là et moi je réponds à ça donc avec un
centre ce qui est non voilà mais tout ce
que je vous dis là ce sont des apostats
riceys j'avais peut-être des a priori et
en fait en les confrontant à ce que des
gens qui ont essayé de se demander
pourquoi est ce qu'on sait ce concert eh
ben j'ai eu moi j'en arrive plus tôt à
cette conclusion
et c'est intéressant de jouer là dessus
alors c'est très difficile de jouer
là-dessus avec gens qui s'intéressent au
raisonnement y bayésiens parce qu'il ya
ces questions sur la terminologie mais
avec le grand public
jouer sur les gens qui doit être senti
que l'inde a priori je pleins d'à priori
mais tu sais que je pensais comme toi
avant est-ce que c'est vrai enfin il
vaut mieux le dire qu'on c'est vrai je
fais pour l'honnêteté là dessus mais
c'est intéressant de votre de dire
attends moi j'étais la personne la plus
bourré d'à priori et j'étais la personne
la plus croyantes avant et dans mon cas
en plus c'est vrai quoi
j'ai été hyper religieux quand j'étais
enfant j'ai j'ai considéré comme vrai
par défaut parce que c'était des savoirs
ancestraux
parce que cette aide et enfin tous les
sophismes habituellement c'est naturel
donc c'est vrai ça vient de chine donc
c'est vrai tous ces trucs là pour moi
c'était c'était pas des sophistes gtd
des homicides de jugement qu'il
permettait d' effectivement dire c'est
très probablement revoir c'est
évidemment évidemment évidemment de tout
à l'heure évidemment que c'est vrai mais
comme j'en suis revenu au travers du
truc d'un long chemin de long
cheminement
je les crues ou des trucs tellement plus
brun deux angles que les gens que j'ai
en face de moi toi sur la l'homéopathie
évidemment que c'est vrai comme des gens
me dis que l'homéopathie c'est c'est de
la flûte gêne je me confronter à eux
non mais vous êtes vous comment est ce
qu'on fait et comment on pouvait pas y
croire avec le sophisme du sert en
bourse et donc c'est vrai enfin
et puis il arrive parfois pas de choses
de me poser d'ailleurs ces gens là il
savait que c'était faux il avait la
priorité c'était fort parce que parce
que dans dont on science en français
bien que c'est faux
et donc en ayant fait le cheminement de
d'essayer de confronter leurs idées
reçues au mieux et c'est ça en fait
parfois c'est des idées qu'ils ont reçus
mais ils ont payé de voir qui recoupe
qui a fait le relais quoi et ben voilà
j'en suis arrivé parfois sur plein de
questions à d a posteriori négatif vous
formalisez ça c'est hyper intéressant et
ça permet d'être dans un dialogue et des
gens mais je croyais comme ça où je
crois pas comme toi et sur ce sujet je
me suis renseigné on me demandait ce que
j'ai des raisons de ne pas croire comme
toi déjà en fête et puis parfois tu t'es
jamais posé la question et là tu arrives
sur un autre niveau où tu dis ça me
semble invraisemblable mon niveau de
leiris j'ai des raisons
j'ai des raisons de ne pas y croire je
te les exposés parce que ça ressemble
beaucoup
ça ça m'évoque des choses que j'ai déjà
vu ailleurs et qui me semble le fos j'ai
un à priori oui qui se basent sur des a
posteriori qui appartiennent à des
deschamps connexes quoi donc le curseur
de vraisemblance je le pose à ce niveau
là où le curseur d'invraisemblances sur
ce sujet donc la porte à une telle
raison et toi pourquoi est ce que tu lui
poses aller là sur les sujets que ce
n'était pas des sujets dont j'en ai rien
à [ __ ] moi je revendique eu le droit
de m'en [ __ ] sur plein de suffisance
ouais qu'est ce que tu penses 2 est ce
que tu penses du 11 septembre une
journée enfin c'est triste à dire mais
je meurs je m'intéresse à plein de trucs
voici les sujets sur lesquels j'ai pas
le temps de me poser des questions je
vais avoir confiance je suis peut-être
me référer aux a priori de tous
peut-être tort de co2 de faire c'est
touristique de jugement là mais mais
surtout des sujets sur lesquels je suis
pas j'ai une appétence intellectuelle et
sur lesquels j'ai l'impression qu'il ya
un intérêt
eh ben je m'aperçois juste que j'ai pas
fini
répondre à une question de talent heures
tout à l'heure je disais je me suis dit
jamais je ferai des articles sur les sur
la médecine
je ne me suis pas lancé dans l'un des
articles sur la médecine sur les
sciences et sur la santé sur les idées
reçues et les fausses représentations
autour des sciences et de la santé parce
que je voyais qu'il y avait les
conneries de dents qui sont fêtés les
conneries pas partout sur plein de
sujets il ya des fausses représentations
sur l'évolution il ya des fausses
représentations sur les trous noirs le
litre au noir les idées qu'on nation
pourquoi est ce que les trous noirs à
thiers tout à es6 voilà le plupart des
gens des fausses représentations
mais ces mesures et c'est étudié en fait
c'est juste parce que ça a des
conséquences gravissimes
je me suis aperçu que quand les gens ils
ont des fausses représentations sur la
façon dont fonctionne le record bas même
si c'est on leur dit voilà tu peux
arrêter de fumer grâce à l'acupuncture
bon que des bombes au pire ça marche pas
mais si l'on qui ça légitime des
représentations énergétique du corps
humain que jours ils ont un cancer que
on a légitimé sa com' médecines
complémentaires non pas d'abord mini
sites alternatifs comme une fine
complémente par glissement
on va légitimer des représentations
énergétique de la guérison là donc les
pierres vont moduler les champs
énergétiques de votre corps et vous
aider à guérir votre cancer mais
peut-être que prendre vos médicaments
donc ça a des conséquences quoi je me
suis aperçu que faire du fact checking
et casser les idées reçues en santé en
fait à avait d un impact d'autant plus
que les médecins et que beaucoup de
scientifiques qui travaillent dans ses
rangs dans ses champs la soie ne savent
pas communiquer soif communique en
entretenant à leur corps défendant des
fausses représentations soit communique
en employant un vocabulaire
qu'entretient sa fausse représentation
soit font leur travail en ayant comme
point de départ la fausse représentation
leurs hypothèses de travail sont oublie
de prendre en compte certains billets
qu'ils vont avoir des effets qui vont
mal médiatisé peut-être qu'ils ont mal
travaillé que leurs résultats
les billets de leur expérience qu'on
peut attendre ma voix avoir des
conséquences c'était un peu un sacerdoce
citoyens quoi ça m'intéressait pas a
priori mais en fait c'est passionnant
voilà pressenti une besoin douar doral
opus il est un devoir
et puis surtout voilà je me dis qu'il ya
un événement majeur là dedans kim a
validé qui fait que je continue à bosser
là dedans vous devez ya le fait que ça
m'amuse et que ça m'intéresse c'est que
ça me passionne et que que je découvre
des concepts faux et que les copains
mais concept que je croyais vrai qu'ils
sont faux et ça c'est trop agréable de
découvrir que j'étais il ya rien de plus
plaisant de des gens qui disent pas que
j'étais juste que j'adore avoir raison
mais en fait j'adore avoir tort ou à
raison c'est il ya beaucoup de gens qui
font de la qui rentre on d'antan qui
s'intéresse au milieu de la zététique
milieu de l'esprit critique ce qu'il
cherche à avoir des armes dans les
débats pour trouver aux autres qu'ils
ont tort ex aequo raison j'ai pas vrai
j'ai peut-être été dans cette démarche
à une époque de ma vie quand j'étais en
je sais pas j'avais 17 ans 18 ans en 20
ans j'étais peut-être un jeune homme
tricon s'il ya des témoins qui veulent
même envoyé des mails perso on dirait
c'est vrai c'était un peu comme ça mais
depuis on
[Musique]
selon nombre d'années je suis vraiment
de rentrer dans l'ordre dans l'eau pose
c'est que j'aime bien avoir tort et que
je cherche à me donner tort et quand
quelqu'un me donne des nouvelles
ressources sur des sujets sur lesquels
je pense avoir bossé je me dis merci
julie merci je pense pas que tu as un
truc question tout était peut-être faux
et le vrai mais je vais je vais analyser
sérieusement si j'ai le temps de le
faire je vais vraiment le faire parce
que si tu me donne tort alors que je
croyais vraiment avoir tout mis en
oeuvre pour que ce soit vrai par contre
si l'anc j'arrive à mon psy en analysant
sérieusement tu as ressources je conclus
que c'est toi 14 ça va décaler mon
curseur de d'invraisemblances soit enfin
en gros ça va la prochaine personne qui
me dit pas mais tu as tort et a pas
encore tous les jeudis à penser la
huitième fois comme le dit la neuvième
fois qu'on me dise chaque fois ça va
rendre encore plus invraisemblable les
allégations des gens qui vont voilà j'ai
encore dégraisser un des événements
décisifs là dedans ça a été un blog que
je trouve super cool sur internet qui
s'appelait l'institut supérieur de
charles alcoologiques c'était drôle
c'est un truc qui écrit écrite comme si
c'était un institut pour former les
charlatans et c'était drôle les articles
c'était voilà vous voulez devenir
charlatans voulait arnaquer les gens
comme ça c'est possible
voilà les arguments que vous devez
employer voilà les sophismes et que les
voilà les ruses intellectuelle voilà ce
que vous devez rétorqué si jamais ils
ont des doutes et ses quais drôle j'ai
contacté l'auteur de ce blog en lui
disant il faut qu'on fasse un truc
ensemble il faut que je sois que
j'utilise mes mes réseaux de
vulgarisation pour aider à faire faire
des conférences
t'es pas te faire venir sur le plateau
d'une des émissions dans lesquelles
j'interviens ou que tu es un un blog
sponsorisés sur j'ai des copains qui
travaillent dans des médias qui on
développe une sortie truc qui est trop
cool existe ce qu'on en parle
vous allez semblait pas particulièrement
intéressé et puis il faut qu'on se
rencontre pour au moins que tu m'aides
afin moi j'aime bien discuter autour
d'un verre
parce que ça va peut-être nourrir mon
travail de vulgarisateur cette approche
un peu frontale de se poser je me dis
est ce qu est ce qu elle fonctionne est
ce que tu sais si ça fonctionne auprès
des gens de se faire passer pour un
charlatan est ce que le second degré
voire le troisième degré fonctionne à
plein est ce que ça ne prêche que les
convaincus enfin elle avait des réponses
qui était un peu il use iv le côté non
je pars envie de boire un verre rouge
on n'aura pas l'occasion de boire un
verre ensemble je me suis peut-être que
je suis passé pour show paris à
peut-être un côté un mec qui s'adresse à
un fanboy à une blogueuse bien peut-être
un côté je sais pas je suis pas je me
posais des questions sur le juste mon
approche sur la façon à ce que j'ai mal
fait mon mail
finalement elle m'a répondu que en fait
c'est juste que elle montrait pas à
paris parce que ne le montrent pas à
paris ou qu'elles descendent pas à paris
on peut importe mais tel ne se rend pas
sur paris parce que parce qu'elle peut
pas bouger parce que parce que depuis
que elle est paralysée
elle peut plus bouger excellent et
paralysé c'est à cause du cancer qu'est
ce qu'elle a et qu'elle a soigné pendant
des années de façon alternative jusqu'au
jour où elle a rencontré quelqu'un qui
était un cancérologue qui lui a dit
c'est qu'on vous soyez pas venu six mois
plus tôt parce que là c'est trop tard et
vous avez plus qu'un an à vivre
c'est con quand même et elle était
passée dans les mains des naturopathes
des gens qui bannit pas les chakras de
tout ce que tu veux
les machins aux pattes il aura été des
psychopathes de ça c'est pas vous dire
qui combat dans la ligue c'est insensé
de la psycho phobie mais dans l'idée
qu'une question il ya quelque chose de
c'est plutôt le psychopathe 102 ya un
côté un peu criminels à te croire
capable de quoi va faire quelque chose
qui relève de l'exercice illégal de la
médecine ou
tel médecin homéopathe de croire que que
parler en marge du consensus
scientifique c'est pas grave c'est pas
grave parce que tu t'es jamais posé la
question de l escaut je parle en marge
du consensus scientifique parce que tu
te dis ouais même si les gens ils
pensent avoir des raisons de croire que
s'il faut moi je préfère rester sur le
fait que j'ai l'impression que c'est
vrai enfin d'être dans la démarche anti
scientifique et celle de dire je veux
donner vous trouvez toutes les raisons
de croire que j'ai raison enfin bref je
sais un peu il use his mon propos mais
est donc et donc voilà et m'apercevoir
que effectivement des gens bien meurt
vraiment des gens que j'aurais aimé
rencontrer des gens avec qui j'aurais
aimé faire un gros bout de chemin
intellectuel et ben je pouvais pas à
cause d'eux à cause de gens qui étaient
des charlatans ça ça m'a ou qui étaient
déjà leur temps leur corps défendant il
pouvait croire que ce qui faisait peur
c'était vrai mais à qui on n'a pas donné
les moyens les outils intellectuels de
s'apercevoir qu'il emmenait les gens sur
la mauvaise pente ou qui les ont laissés
là où on est du domaine criminel mais
ouais c'est pas bien de voir des
psychopathes de la nature ou les
psychopathes sait si mal d'avoir accès à
cette facilité argumentative d'emblée
ces mots là les quelques minutes mais tu
vois l'idée en tout cas donc ça ça m'a
confirmé qu'il fallait que je continue à
bosser dans le milieu de la
vulgarisation scientifique médicaux
médicaux santé quoi
voilà voilà voilà les racines de mon
parcours c'est que c'est bon ça c'est
assez important de dire que j'avais
comme des conséquences sur la santé
beaucoup de gens que je suis un délicat
jeu titre revenir sur les a priori parce
que tu as à élucider un point est le
fait d où l idée comment soyez
rapidement un point qui mériterait
peut-être un peu plus de discussions en
fait c'était tel que tu l'a présenté à
me semble qu'il ya en fait on peut
distinguer deux types d'à priori est-ce
qu'il ya le priori beauvaisiens qui est
vraiment là priori que tu devrais avoir
avant d'avoir vu les données et
généralement c'est pas les gens ne sont
pas avoir un prix parisiens c'est
extrêmement difficile
par contre il ya un a priori avant le
prix parisiens qui l a priori que l'on a
avant d'avoir réfléchi et c'est souvent
c'est à priori là que les gens en tête -
le prix soit sans réflexion et souvent
c'est juste intéressant du coup assez il
ya un peu de son regard de façon basique
moitié parisienne dont il y aura trois
phases d'apprentissage
le premier c'est la priori non réfléchi
et on est tous passés par là et donc en
pratique parce qu'on a des puissants
véhicules finis ils économiques
positives ont obligé d'en passer par là
toute façon donc on est toujours avec
des quelque part les a priori non
réfléchie et pour pouvoir se rapprocher
dans du bon apple store il rivalisera
qui sera un peu l'objectif claironné
malaisiens ont peu d'avoir faire cette
première étape décidé d'avoir un a
priori bayésiens que moi j'appelle la
posteriori mais enfin voila c'est enfin
de terminologie et c'est intéressant de
s'apercevoir que en fait il manque un
mot intermédiaire et que moi dans ma
pratique de vulgarisation j'ai préféré
écarter la notion d' a posteriori barry
des pourparlers d'à priori et valaisans
en parlant du dés a posteriori parce
qu'en fait la notion de l'a priori et
l'expression mais a posteriori on
l'emploie en fait de leur accorder sur
du langage courant
quand tu dis quand tu essayes de
vulgariser
la bourse et bayésienne dire ça comme ça
à des gens en employant bois priori et a
posteriori
dès lors qu'en fait tu rapport à la
représentation ça ça correspond pas il
ya déjà tout un travail de
déconstruction à faire mais moi je suis
le pari qu'il faudrait que les gens
changent leur robot a posteriori les
trouve un mot à poster posteriori
histoire et qui en fait on a plein de
soucis là dedans sur les idées reçues
autour des mots c'est comme quand tu en
plein boom au code génétique
ça les gens qui ont l'impression qu'il
ya un codage donc à un codeur il y a
quand tu discutes avec des
systématiciens les dix ans tire une
balle dans le pied en fait on a en
utilisant un vocabulaire qui créez votre
présentation
et je pense après on peut en discuter
peut creuser cette question ici ou
ailleurs mais que d'employer les mois a
priori et a posteriori a enfin pour
décrire deux des trois types de deux
rapports à la vraisemblance ça comme ça
et que ces mots là sans emploi il est
une autre façon par une autre partie des
gens créent des problèmes dans la façon
de vulgariser le le le les choses c'est
marrant quand j'ai commencé à formaliser
tout ça je crie pharma les titres et en
fait j'ai à chaque fois que je lisais
des choses sur le théorème de beille les
vôtres et sur la pensée qui est derrière
sur les raisonnements qui sont derrière
jeu josé la correction
naturellement dans ma tête j'avais
presque l'impression que les auteurs
faisait un abus de langage fait c'est
pas c'est pas ça c'est pas une question
d'être double langage c'est une question
de hacker leur moment tu emploies quels
mots courts du parc de hasard tu
passeras nicolas louvre il avait fait
une petite idée des définitions durera
du hasard qu'il avait listé 9
définitions possibles du hasard donc dès
que tu commences à vue lui faire une
vulgarisation de quelque chose d'une
notion de hasard
en fait il faut prendre le temps de voir
si tout le monde enfin où chacun se
situe à priori et où est à la limite si
l'on à deuxième sens en tête et puis de
mettre ça à plat quoi et donc voilà
c'est sur la question de comment
vulgariser les a priori ce qu'on a sur
le mot a priori je pense que c'est une
discussion de force en savoir sur
quelles sont les meilleures façons de de
queen que ces idées donc voir mois le
parti que j'ai pris sur dans mon livre
et sur la chaîne s'est distingué des
préjugés pas réfléchi de préjugés qui
serait d'ailleurs et je pense que c'est
utile parce que dans cette idée de
préjugés il s'est jugé avant donc on
peut se demander avant quoi donc je
pense qu'il ya avant deux choses avant
avoir réfléchi en effet du coup il n'y a
rien pour elle mais aussi avant d'avoir
observé les données et je pense que
souvent on donne beaucoup d'importance
ou donnés alors que soit il ya un
travail préalable extrêmement important
avant même d'avoir regardé donné mais
pourquoi est ce qu'on pense le compenser
ce que le préjugé que l'on avait était
un projet réfléchi
exactement je pense que dans pas mal de
façon de vulgariser un peu patience on
insiste beaucoup sur ce côté de données
alors que souvent ce qui me semble le
plus d'efficience pas forcément le même
la prise en compte des données c'est
plus ce travail de réflexion a priori et
en particulier pendant que dans le cadre
de l'homéopathie chauffe on saute très
très vite sur les résultats empiriques
de tests seront des dizaines compteront
double aveugle alors qu'il ya un travail
de préjugés battu très importants comme
c'est un atout clé mon travail c'est ma
façon de travailler c'est justement de
partir vraiment de ces questions est pas
là vous voulez parler de l'homéopathie
est quelqu'un enfin moi j'ai en plus je
que je dis est vrai quoi après vous
pouvez le dire on n'y croyons pas mais
quand générale jeudi quand les gens
commencent à parler d' homo comme j'aime
bien le mot pâti à qu'est ce que tu
penses de logo pâtit
j'ai plusieurs façons de le formuler
mais je dis moi la phytothérapie j'ai à
peu près pas grand chose contre lumumba
tige est beaucoup plus de griefs tourner
comme ça je trouves tu peux pas qu'on va
pas je le redis ça dépend quand tu
parles d'homéopathie tu parles mais ça
que ce soit en formule est comme ça
c'est devenu une stratégie consciente
mais ça ne l'a pas toujours été c'est
plutôt à force de vos dents de discuter
je leur dis bah moi autant la
phytothérapie sam j'étais raison d'avoir
des jets des arguments pour drouot petit
j'ai plein d'arguments contre les a
posteriori contre jets et les gens sont
hyper surpris quoi c'est pareil et paf
est pas foutu l'attend loue donc pour
toi c'est phytothérapie c'est là des
plantes et lé molécules des plantes qui
interviennent dans ton corps je sais pas
moi à l'heure tu prends l'écran des
grandes représentations il peut aller
très vite aux grandes représentations
l'aspirine il dérive de la cites
salicylique donc c'est l'acide
acétylsalicylique hyderi de l'acide
assez bon bref
ouais bon voilà les histoires du sol etc
il va là y'a plein de médicaments la
digitaline et le voilà les mais la
pharmacopée qui vient de des plantes
bombe à la cool donc ça il ya des
molécules qui interagissent avec ton
organisme
donc ok mais mais l'homéopathie c'est
une autre histoire quand même ça ne
s'oublie pas à cette même logique sap a
été inventé dans cette optique là et oui
ils sont surpris et donc tu dialogue
avec eux sur quels sont leurs
représentations
tu leur demandes de leurs les verbaliser
a parfois ils connaissent le truc et ce
qui est intéressant aussi c'est par
exemple de discuter avec des homéopathes
de la représentation de l'homéopathie
mais je me suis parfois je m'imaginais
que ça allait être des choses très
épique sur ce passionnante des
homéopathes qui croit absolument pas
hautes dilutions aux très hautes
dilutions quand tu leur dis voilà boiron
leur dirai qu'ils boiront c'est pas
individualiser quoi ils ont emmené des
trucs du fabricant série pour moi pas tu
dois travailler à nu a donc ce don tante
alice de représentations déjà le le labo
qui produit le plus pâti en série donc
ça fait pas partie de ce que tu
considères valide ok cool et donc un
coût le coule dans le sang ce je le note
quoi et et alors parme si je te dis
ce que je dis je sais pas moi 2 une
plante 1 milliards de milliards de
milliards de milliards de milliards de
km dans une autre démission ça c'est ça
c'est ça n'a aucun sens
par contre les faibles discussions sais
pas si bête je veux dire un vaccin c'est
quoi c'est l'exposition a une petite
dose de quelque chose
et finalement c'est comme ça qu'on
conçoit la notion de mythe réalisation
s'exposer à de petites doses de poison
pour petit à petit être insensible
l'homéopathie c'est ça donc toi ton la
représentation d' homo pâte ses huit
réalisations
comment dirais-je vaccination et
dilution d'une molécule qui a un effet
sur le corps même combat quoi ok mais en
fait je parle si je parle de ce sujet
avec toi on va pas du tout avoir le même
type de discussions et ont peut-être
combat je l'échangé des fissures plein
de trucs que c'est si quelqu'un avait
des croyances qu'on peut quand qu'en
pointant un télescope vers une
constellation dans lesquelles il ya un
trou noir puis en nettoyant la lentille
de temps télescope et en nettoyant l'eau
de lavage un milliard de fois et là
parce que on a pointé dans une direction
d'un trou noir on peut soigner les
manques affectifs alors un truc
ésotérique et poétique est donc déjà
savoir de quoi enfin c'est indispensable
pour pas perdre ton temps et puis toi
respect pour la personne et parce que
parfois elle a des raisons que tu ils
l'ont amené à croire qu'ils vont te
changer ta vision du monde ou changer
tes réflexions sur comment est ce que
les gens en viennent à croire c'est ce
pape le comment est ce qu'on sait ce
qu'on sait c'est comment est-ce qu'on en
vient à penser ce qu'on sait par les
chemins tortueux ait des gens qui
étaient anti bio enfin le bio au sens de
l'alimentation bio et qui serait venue
pro bio comment est-ce qu'ils en sont
venus là pour moi tu peux passer d'être
anti à propos des gens qui disaient des
gens qui croyaient à ça c'est des gens
qui m'ont énormément intéressé les gens
qui étaient sur une pente sous 12 qui
les mener vers la négation des crimes
contre l'humanité la négation de la
shoah coup de saïfi qui donc basculé
dans le contraire parce que en ce sens
en faisant ce travail de négationniste
sincères ils se ils avaient ils se
croyaient révisionnistes qui croyaient
que les historiens travail est mal et
bavent ils sont arrivés en fait à
comprendre que
alors qu'en fait tant dans une
historiens ont bien travaillé ils ont
des raisons de comprendre que ils ont
des preuves
objectif il ya bien une extermination
massive des juifs d europe sepa et donc
comprendre comment les gens basculent de
lentilles vers le pro ou le contraire
c'est intéressant de autant d'un point
de vue modélisation de comment est-ce
que les gens chemine au temps de surfer
cas particulier parce que c'est hyper
intéressant quelqu'un revient un jour
virement me dire oui moi les chambres à
gaz la studi attentats
c'est qu'il ya des ressources ont été
produites de réfutation de cfa 2 2d
bunting de ce que tu crois est vrai et
si tu t'opposes sincèrement ceux qui se
tenant par ce que parce qu'internet
c'est facile d'ouvrir les vannes de ces
choses en dépit des lois qui interdisent
de 2 voilà en france la loi gayssot fait
interdire de poser sur le tapis des
choses qui nie à l'existence de faits
que les historiens
enfin sur ces sujets là quoi et il ya
plein de raisons moi j'ai plutôt
tendance à penser que c'est que ces lois
sont positives mais elles ont des effets
pervers c'est que les gens s'expose il
suffit d'aller sur une un site belge
d'aller sur n'importe à internet c'est
portes ouvertes parce que tu es donc tu
exposé à c est en fait il faudrait avoir
ou être exposé à la réfutation essayé
réfutation existe les preuves que les
arguments sur le l'existence des
chambres à gaz par l'épreuve-reine pas
les armures l'épreuve tout en le sens
évidence les centres est une preuve
définitive quoi delà de tout ça c'est
vrai elles existent elles ont été menées
par des gens qui ont fait un travail de
fond et c'est peut-être l'effet l'effet
pervers du fait de ne pas avoir
l'occasion de disons que si tu commences
à réfuter quelque chose dont personne ne
parle sur la place publique on va te
reprocher de faire la promotion de leurs
idées c'était arrivé tu dis voilà
faurisson dit de la même ferrari mais
vous commencez à parler toi ils ont
alors que personne au mieux personnes en
entendre parler
jeudi 20 mai mais on en fait y en a qui
toi ils vont sur les sites d'alain soral
ils vont sur les sites dieudonné machin
ils sont exposés à ça donc
alors je sais pas j'ai quand même
tendance à dire que c'est bon bref en
tout cas grand débat mais c'est
intéressant de dialoguer avec des gens
qu'on fait ce cheminement
on revient aux omoplates et que tu vois
que c'est que leur leur système de
pensée tu vas commencer à pouvoir après
à attaquer les données exactement comme
on disait tout à l'heure
les expériences ont essayé de vérifier
si la petite dose ce produit était censé
avoir cet effet si tu donnes un
médicament qui peut être produire des
suées as tu te prends une molécule qui
en grande quantité te donne des suées
voilà et donc tu vas la diluer des
milliards de fois
fourques dans l'espoir que ça produisent
l'effet inverse sans arriver à des très
hautes dilutions à des dilutions
invraisemblable ça ce test et tu
demandes
enfin parce que ça a été testée est ce
que vous savez comment ça a été testé et
tu te commencé à discuter des protocoles
veut dire bah ouais c'était discuter ça
a été dit qu'une faillite est étudiée il
ya des gens qui ont fait des protocoles
en double aveugle contre placebo oui
quand même
et puis tu peux rentrer dans la donne et
tu peux les regarder les études qui ont
été encornés puis tu peux voir
travailler avec cette personne pour voir
s'il ya des billets et ça prend pas
beaucoup je te parle de deux pas de
choses qui sont sur des semaines ces
choses qui pour ce faire une halte en
ruine après midi ou en quelques heures
sur les envoyez moi votre donné je vais
où votre méta analyse et puis on va
regarder si vous allez faire changer
d'avis que vous allez me faire douter
c'est peut-être que c'est moi qui vous
faire douter en vous donnant les contre
arguments et est donc voilà voir est ce
que vous allez faire bouger mon curseur
sur cette sous-catégorie d'homéopathie
qui s'appelle voix partie des bases des
spoilers en faisant ce travail avec
toute la sincérité qui était la mienne
et en partant même de mes appris de mes
préjugés c'est intéressant d'être les
autres emplois de d'utiliser préjugé
plutôt qu'à priori jouer tout le temps
de contourner la difficulté des mots qui
sont souvent employés dans ta discipline
c'est intéressant de voir que ce serait
intéressant de les évaluer quels sont
les les choses quand le plus grand
impact employés préjugés employés a
priori bref c'est une étude intéressante
alors on n'a pas beaucoup de données sur
cette voie là mais c'est interdit un
beau projet sur l'utilisation du mot
précis mais
donc tout ça pour dire que ça prend pas
trop de temps et que même malgré mon
cheminement la grand mère qui a qui m'a
aidé a plus à voir d'insomnie grâce je
mets toutes les gaines et nous on ne vit
pas en me donnant le nouveau petit et le
et ben j'en arrive à la conclusion que
n'ont toujours pas produit de preuve
concluante et que les preuves qu'ils
avancent sont beaucoup plus fragiles le
méthodologiquement extra que les
expériences qu'ils existent l'actualité
ne veut ni et parfois que des protocoles
plus malins et c'est sûrement pour
écarter encore plus de billets qui
pointe direction d'une efficacité et
voilà on peut considérer que pas écoute
le monde d'harry potter il ya des trucs
vrai de droit revenir ouais mais même
les mêmes le coup de pointer un
télescope vera vers une une galaxie dans
lesquelles il ya des trous noirs
utilisait le lot de lavage pour soigner
à la limite je veux bien dire ça marche
ça c'est un truc que j'ai développé à
une verbalisation de des choses que j'ai
je marche je pense que d'autres
l'avaient fait mais que j'ai mis
vraiment dans ma pratique de
vulgarisateur dit ok peut-être que c'est
vrai peut-être que peut-être que le
monde d'harry potter et efficace
peut-être que diluer des trous noirs ça
marche mais ça s'évalue ça se mesure et
indiscuté 11 ans et comment est-ce qu'on
peut l'évaluer et dit avoir aussi sept
rapports à l'autre
en lisant je veux bien mettre ton truc
qui me semble fou fou est vrai et tu tu
as donné quand même que le niveau
devrait semblant sebha pour plein de
raisons
on a enfin le par rapport à la cohérence
interne de choses qui ont réussi à
s'emboîter les unes dans les autres dans
le savoir humain et qu'il ya plein de
trucs qui sont tombés pas parce qu'on
voulait pas qui mais juste parce qu'ils
tenaient pas quoi et n'est pas n'est pas
dans l'absolu il fabrique n'est pas dans
le sac version le pronom que c'était des
illusions nas et de la narration que
c'était des des représentations
intuitive du monde qui décomptent d'y
aller allez voir d'un peu plus près ne
tenait pas on a un système assez
cohérent avec plein de trous 1
mais son truc et j'ai l'impression qu'il
rentre pas là dedans donc
parle l'incohérence avec le truc est
cohérent et qui avait un effet sur le
monde c'est à dire tu t'es tu dis là les
tailles des le nombre de rats les cernes
des arbres
donc tu fais là d'andreu chronologie tu
t'es dit et glaces des pôles et étudie
tout ça bien tout pointe vers le fait
qu' on a à peu près les mêmes courbes de
quantité de dioxyde de l'oxygène fin
d'oxydé de carbone et les mêmes courbes
d'évolution dans l'atmosphère donc tu
vois qu'il ya une cohérence globale qui
permet de dire qu'il ya un consensus
assez ça qu'on pourrait appeler le
consensus c'est le fait que plein de
disciplines peuvent se nourrir d'un
savoir commun que les données des uns
peuvent appuyer celles des autres et que
ça créera et que dès qu'ils tuent fait
un coup de sonde dans le réel alors je
sais que tu aimes pas à cette image mais
imaginons que ça soit une approximation
du travail des chercheurs à que tu
tentes de vérifier d'autres donné tort
en essayant de faire des courses en
temps réel qui attend ça ressemble
plutôt à south la température du monde
elle est de la réalité elle est plutôt à
a dit nono pharma dissous avant d'unités
qu'on appellera réalité les préjugés ils
allaient dans ce sens là en face à plein
de choses à voir tout ça d'entre eux est
cohérent alors je fais plein de gestes
c'est qu'on poursuit tu écoutes mais on
a un mur là je fais des dessins sur le
monde
mais bon va envoyer tu valides et donc
quand tu es bien arriver dit voilà moi
je peut guérir en utilisant ce truc là
dessus ni mais ça ça correspond à rien
ça correspond à des choses il appartient
à un domaine qui est la pensée magique
la pensée autres qui a été testé sur
savent pas aussi ils disent ça c'est
inexplorés par les 106 avait été
explorée est exclu ça a été explorée et
de réfuter d'assez des ans des
formulations optimale team améris les
cheveux mais 10 10 la science ne
s'intéresse pas à l'homéopathie
aucune étude phare l'heure aucune étude
ne l'a encore prouvé que c'est pas comme
ça qu'il veut dire aucune étude n'a
encore prouvé ça veut ça peut
sous-entendre qu'aucune étude n'a été
menée ou qu'elles ont été mal fait ou
que ainsi à toutes les études qui ont
essayé de montrer que la ds ma patrie
l'immense majorité des études qui ont
été menées et qu'on prouvait que et
celle qui que sa main on vise le fait
que c'est très peu vraisemblable que ça
soit vrai toutes les études pointent
dans la direction du fait que ça repose
ce qu'est ce que c'est du vent ou que
ses désillusions qui repose sur des
effets
10 qui effet placebo et que toutes les
études qui pourraient parce qu'elles
existent pour elle et c'est à quoi
laisser penser qu'ils pourraient laisser
accroire qu'il ya quelque chose quand on
y regarde de plus près eh ben il ya de
bonnes raisons de d'imaginer soit de par
leur proportion que c'est des faux
positifs de soi par de la façon dont les
réseaux ont été conçus sur sa point de
faire des erreurs méthodologiques soit
par des délégations de financement que
ça prendrait un gros billet de
publication est donc de dire la personne
voilà ton truc moi dans mon jeu peut pas
partir avec un préjugé un a priori
bayésiens positif et donc le dire aussi
le verbaliser et ça change tout ça
change tout va discussion ça change tout
à la façon dont tu peux débattre aussi
alors à pourvoir tenir ces exemples de 2
mo pa ti ou tu perds de jeu quand tu es
ab ça le fait que la dilution je fais
l'effet opposé mais j'ai fait possible
de similitude est devenu dur donc donc
tu me parlais remonte à fin ce que tu
vas parler cesson s'est encore fait on
va très vite car une expérience pour
deviser comprenant deux et tout ça en
coiffant révocation et verson l'appel à
et je pense qu'il ya un travail
nécessaire à nice et un travail utile
préalable qui est vraiment de poser la
question mais prouesse qu'on pense ce
qu'on pense et qu'est-ce que je ne serai
plus justifiée à penser à vos propos de
l'homéopathie
ah oui attention parce que là je parle
de dialogue à face à une personne après
tu peux te s'était légèrement différente
un travail sur soi même parce que tu y
compris avec une autre personne ce que
souvent en fait sur ces sujets qu'on est
l'objectif d'une offre non mais souvent
ceux sur ces sujets on n'a pas souvent
assez réfléchi et je suis convaincu que
oui la plupart des gens qui s'expriment
ne sont pas posé de questions c'est ça
les gens c'est ça c'est une illusion un
préjugé qui a absolument pas réfléchi il
oui en fait il y avait déjà beaucoup de
progrès à faire on dit en les amenant à
aa
à reconnaître qu'il est vieux et que
ensuite oublier un peu lors leurs
préjugés pas réfléchi et si de réfléchir
à qu'est ce que serait un projet
réfléchi sur l'euro pâtit d'accord je
veux ou tu veux rien oui oui on est on
est d'accord en fait que le travail ne
bégaye le travail vraiment passionnant
c'est de me poser cette question vous
savez vous croyez savoir un truc qu'est
ce qui vous permettrait d'avoir pourquoi
est ce que vous pensez ce que vous
vendez france à la première question ces
doudous vient d'où vient cette pensée
que vous avez est ce que ça peut être
compris de façon pourquoi vous pensez ce
que vous pensez c'est aussi saignant un
truc est aussi j'en veux dire c'est quoi
la généalogie de votre pensée c'est quoi
le cv de votre pensée pourquoi est-ce
que vous avez adopté cette parce que
c'est une question facile ça va oui c
est un truc c'est que nous y réfléchit
jamais ben peu de gens le met en mots et
peut- on intègre dans la la phase de
discussion ou dans leur réflexion
personnelle sur les choses quoi pourquoi
est-ce que je je considère comme vrai xy
cette chose est juste de dire pourquoi
je crois que les voitures assez ma
famille mes parents qui m'ont dit ça
parce que ma menace nazie mais c'est pas
suffisant si tu en arrives à la staff
est en progrès non ouais mais en garde
ils ce sont les gens vont pas jusque là
il ya une banda dont ma démarche le
médiator dans l'habitude d'aller faire
le plein de vulgarisateur il ya ce
travail de dire aux gens qu'est ce qui
t'a convaincu on s'est un peu
problématique pour moi je vais
t'expliquer pourquoi mais je trouve que
déjà intéressant des roquettes à plein
d'arguments lequel pour toi le plus
décisif dans le sens et que c'est quoi
le sens de ce que je te dis moi qui
dialoguent avec totti a une opinion
c'est que est ce qu'à un moment il ya un
truc où tu t'es dit ça c'est à cause de
ça
j'y crois c'est quoi qui est ton point
de basculement dans ton parcours mental
est ce qu'il ya eu un os que ç'a
toujours été là et l'heure n'est qu'ils
font ça pour piéger l'adversaire parce
qu'ils se disent en fait peut-être
facilement réfuter et je vais construire
son système alors qu'en vrai on croise
comprend rarement pour une seule raison
donc parfois dirait l'autre c'est quoi
l'argument décisif kita mais que c'est
presque alors consciemment ou non un
piège enfin intentionnellement ou non un
piège de débatteur pour amener l'autre
on réfute son truc qui ont dit et donc
je réfute toute attente à part en fait
ce serait plus intelligent 10h c'est
quoi les moments les instants qui ont
validé à croire qu'ils ont renforcé
selon la croyance dans ce que tu
appelles connaissant son talent un
élément qui fait partie de son système
de pensée et son système de valeurs
sociales de ce que tu appelles les
connaissances et de tes connaissances et
puis remonté et c'est marrant mais chez
les journalistes
je me suis confronté plein de fois avec
des journalistes quand j'ai abordé la
notion de champion et bourgaud pâtit sac
lâchait et y en a plusieurs
j'ai appris que la loom obtient une
place dans leur histoire familiale
centrale leur père est tombé au patois
c'est fou mais c'est marrant d'aller
réaction incroyable
j'avais fait un article sur la pollution
liés à l'armée à la suite
enfin l'euro quand tu brûles dû boire
les conséquences que ça sur les
brochures machin et le taux de pollution
comment mesurer le taux de pollution
liée à la combustion du bois et comment
tu déchires ainsi alors que commence une
différence une particules fines de bois
d'une particules fines de machin si ton
appareil sert juste à mesurer la taille
des particules une question intéressante
c'est vrai quand on nous dit oui dans le
bassin parisien
dans paris intra muros là les particules
fines sont dus à 23% plus ou moins je
sais pas quoi à la combustion du bois
tendre comment tu vérifies ça c'est quoi
les outils ms moment cela avait
intéressé je me suis que c'était
intéressant de donner ses clés de
réflexion au public justement si jamais
on d'ios les conneries on peut pas
mesurer st puis ben voilà le sujet
m'intéressait les effets de la pollution
je fais ce travail je m'aperçois les
données sont pas ouf
mais c'est pas dégueulasse non plus ça
mérite d'être représentés à son niveau
de la qualité des données
peut-être que d'autres études prouvent
rex et le kung fu vers je pense l'avoir
l'avoir suffisamment exprimé dans le
sujet mais voilà je n'étais pas c'était
pas l'étude du chat qui paie toi et je
me suis aperçu parmi les les bons
retours que j'avais deux confrères qui
avaient appris des choses
le lecteur qui avait pris des choses de
lecteurs qui deux confrères qui avait
rien appris mais qui avait mené ce
travail intellectuel de leur côté et
habite hissé à peu de choses près les
mêmes réflexions dirais ok tu jouerais
pas formulé comme ça jamais mais et puis
la réaction d'un journaliste médical
d'assez médiatique qui m'est tombé
dessus très bizarre en disant façon
c'est des conneries je dis ben moi je me
suis penché sur l'étude et sa réaction
ça avait été j'ai pas besoin de lire
l'étude pour que savard c'est faux et ça
va lui poser des questions alors je sais
je confonds peut-être deux événements je
me fais une parenthèse note à moi-même
c'est qu'en fait j'ai fait plusieurs
articles sur ce sujet je sais plus si
c'est dans un des premiers articles ou
d'inde et second article sur ce sujet
qui a eu cette réaction qui était je
n'ai pas besoin de lire cet article
porter que ces fonds bon j'en avais
rigoler ai dit que ce n'était pas une
très belle réaction de sa part surtout
que ces départs à une étude si mauvaise
que ça c'était pas une mauvaise créé
voudrait dire qu'il avait un a
posteriori au sens où l'entend est ce qu
il avait suffi est-ce qu'il avait
tellement bossé sur le sujet que sont le
curseur de vraisemblance de cette étude
là il était enfin il fallait vraiment
que c'était une soit hyper béton qu'elle
a été menée pendant 20 ans sur 200 mille
sujets pour arriver à les faire changer
d'avis quoi parce qu'il avait déjà
regardé plein de trucs cave en quoi et
qui s'était peut-être peut-être que
c'est moi qu'il fallait bosser quoi les
belgique rosult fruits et puis j'en ai
mangé en fait j'avais pas si mal bossé
que ça voilà on sent un peu la biblio
derrière on écrire mon article je
m'étais pas trompé et je n'avais pas
compris sa réaction jusqu'au jour où je
vois une une interview de lui et où il
est dans son cabinet est derrière lui
hirsch foot cheminée et donc danser dans
sa tâche aveugle dans les choses sur
lesquelles il peut pas admettre même
s'il est la combustion du barbu c'est
une interprétation la parent
mais je me dis peut-être que ça a pu
jouer dans sa réaction épidermique sur
ce sujet en particulier parce que sur
plein de sujets je le trouve très
pertinent et cette réaction qui ne lui
ressemblait pas eh ben elle pouvait
peut-être peut-être ligne et qui voit le
fait que là bas ils aiment bien sans feu
de cheminée quoi que j'ai tort peut-être
que c'est un autre narratif qui est qu
une autre explication mais néanmoins
cette image
imaginons ce que j'aime dire n'est pas
la bonne explication métaphoriquement si
c'était un conte pour enfants un point
contre un peu chiant mais ils attendent
de la de l'homme qui essaye de
comprendre pourquoi est-ce-que est les
particules fines la bla bla et ça
pourrait être la chute de l'histoire et
est même dans l'idée que ça pourrait
défauts sont à l'origine de nos refus
l'origine aux zones de nos tâches
aveugle et de nos des choses qu'on veut
pas voir ça peut être ça le revers c'est
vrai quand je parlais des antilles de
l'antisémitisme au travers de ne pas
parler d'antisémitisme en parlant des
gens qui sont dans une logique
négationnistes à propos de deux des
chambres à gaz
c'est intéressant de valable pour ceux
que ça intéresse de travailler sur ces
sujets de d'aller sonder pourquoi est ce
que les gens en sont arrivés sur cette
pente là dans cette pub à s'intéresser à
ces sujets ce que c'est par curiosité
historique par un intérêt sur la méthode
historique le film rigolo c'est de voir
qu'il ya plein de gens qui s'intéressent
à sa part par eux par besoin de
renforcer leur antisémitisme qui est
déjà prêt union par ailleurs les gens
ils rigolaient à propergol et c'est pas
drôle mais je veux parler d'une personne
dont j'avais suivi un peu le cheminement
intellectuel je me disais comment si on
arrivait de passer d'un travail et c'est
sérieux à petit à petit a adhéré à ce
qu' a priori assez sains avec un niveau
de conviction personnelle à des théories
de négationnistes et je dise en
plaisantant ça sa copine
enfin on son conjoint ou sa conjointe à
la tête plaquée pour lui il faut une vie
fait il a dû en avoir du ressentiment et
ça à du renfort
quand je me suis ça se trouve c'est pas
une hypothèse car c'est peut-être une
hypothèse gratuit c'est complètement
faux
mais peut-être ya des gens qui sont dans
cette logique et pourquoi parce que
quand je discute avec des gens qui me
semble défendre certaines positions
géopolitiques non pas par sur l'état
d'israël et ses pas pour des valeurs
mais vraiment pour des préjugés
antisémites ou par des pour avec une
logique et bien ils ont un historique de
friction avec un vif en particulier
illzach en français là dedans est bon
qu'ils ont aussi des arguments atroce
que j'ai entendu de gens qui disaient
chambres à gaz n'existe pas les juifs
essaye de nous le faire croire
parce que ça leur permet d'avoir d'avoir
dans leur dossier qu'il aura comme s'ils
étaient dans leurs dossiers qui leur a
permis d'avoir l'état d'israël c'était
un argument de poids
et bien franchement des mecs qui
agissent comme ça mériterait d'être
brûlé évidemment fait tu dis les jambes
à gaz n'ont pas existé et c'est dommage
parce que parce que parce qu'il faudrait
les brûler ça ouais ouais franchement
mais pourquoi tu crois que ça n'a pas eu
lieu puisque tu penses parce que
personne ne peut en aucun système
idéologique c'est gentil petit nazi
jamais jamais il aurait été assez aussi
loin qui peut penser à brûler des gens
parce qu'ils sont nés dans la même forme
c'était vraiment des échanges que j'ai
eus 1 les gens qui disent les nazis
n'ont pas pu faire ça parce que j'ai eu
quand même ici
il voulait juste un coup de l'espace du
tard et qu'ils te disent donc ils n'ont
pas pu aller dans cette extrémité c'est
un impensable mais dix minutes plus tard
et 10 quand même 3 la juriste a vu qu'à
la mise ils ont fait croire que ça
existait il le mériterait d'être face à
sarlat si tu dis si tu peux pas être un
institut dialogue avec des gens comme ça
c'est parce que le sujet du
négationniste qu'il faut aborder c'est
le sujet de toutes qu'est ce qui les a
amenés alors c'est quoi ton ce qu'ils
pensaient ouaip article initial le mais
il y en a d'autres c'est pas du tout ça
leur parcours intellectuel et donc voilà
si vous voulez vous vous confronter à
des débats avec des c'est pas juste un
complotisme septembre l'ancien
complotisme antisémite qui est passé du
faux faux je pense qu'il faut être 4e
dan au 5e dan des scripts d'esprit
critique et d'histoire et de comprendre
ce que c'est que la méthode historique
l'épistémologie derrière l'histoire pour
se confronter à ces gens là qui se
baky et passe beaucoup de temps à
trouver des dirigeants flatter leur
leurs idées reçues dans le sens du poil
et à trouver tout ce qui va confirmer
leurs idées reçues le biais de
confirmation fonctionne à plein là c'est
que je prenais des monnaies des grands
quoi je sais pas est ce intéressant en
tout cas de pont je savoir qu' il ya
plusieurs choses qui peuvent amener les
gens et parfois c'est des événements de
leur vie
dbt des gens qu'ils ont fréquentés qui
chauffe très lointaines des hommages qui
leur empêche de remettre en question il
faut aussi le respecter ça et à propos
de ces représentations qu'on a et de de
l'histoire qui nous personnels il ya
d'autres choses qu'il faut en prendre en
compte et qui ont un lien avec la
bienveillance qu'on a dans les débats et
même dont j'aimerais à prendre l'exemple
de ce qu'a longtemps fait l'observatoire
zététique l'association grenobloise
l'ours qui testait des des personnes qui
pensaient avoir des pouvoirs par des
pouvoirs de sourcils des choses comme ça
de s'enquérir de ce qu amener les gens à
se convaincre eux mêmes qu'ils avaient
ses compétences et quelles seraient les
conséquences de lait de leurs deux
d'être confronté au fait que peut-être
si jamais l'expérience déplacer la
vraisemblance de leur à l'égard de leurs
pratiques vers le sepa vrai ça marche
pas en fait t'as pas vraiment ce pouvoir
c'est juste une illusion
la perceptive et autres quelles sont les
conséquences ça intéresse c'est quand tu
veux débattront tu veux comprendre
pourquoi les gens croient ce qu'ils
croient pourquoi les gens croient ce
qu'ils croient et pourquoi des gens que
je pense qu'ils pensent savoir aussi
quelles seraient les conséquences de
faire changer train de le savoir permet
aussi de mesurer les conséquences de
tout
de ton interactions et ça c'est aussi
très peu fier c'est ce que au sein de
l'observatoire tesis qu'ils ont
développées et j'ai l'impression qu'en
fait ils ont donné un sens à la pratique
et éthique dans les et éthique
expérimental poids contre quand tu fais
d'experts des évaluations de
d'allégations de qu'il ya introduit
énormément d'humanité de bienveillance
ça me fait un peu penser donc quand on
fait les diagrammes sur pour définir
l'évidence based medecine la médecine
basée sur les preuves
on a souvent l'impression que c'est
juste pour l'épreuve l'épreuve l'épreuve
mais il ya la pratique du médecin et à
l'épreuve et il ya ce que vous le
patient et c'est à l'intersection où ces
trois de ces trois choses que le médecin
alors mettons les mamans le combo il
semble licence il croit vrai il ya les
preuves qui vont plus ou moins allé dans
le même sens mais aussi les envies les
besoins la présentation du patient et ça
c'est aussi décisif que le reste donc à
ça s'il ya un équilibrage à trois
plateaux qui se fait et ben quand essaie
de comprendre enfin quand tu es dans une
démarche d'évaluation du réel mesuré à
quel point l'évaluation du réel peut
avoir des conséquences sur toile sur
l'autre agression gestion durant
l'évaluation des allégations le la
confrontation aux données ou là
l'évaluation des données alors comme ça
qu'est ce que ça peut avoir comme
conséquence il ça
le résultat d une direction qui te plaît
pas fois c'est bien parce que de
l'anticiper parce qu'on anticipant même
avant d'avoir les résultats tu peux dire
jamais mais même si c'est vrai je le
dirai que c'est faux déjà à six si c'est
faux c'est que j'ai dû me tromper
ouais télé pourquoi que d'où vient ce
préjugé l'heure il est où ce problème
qu'est ce qui pourquoi ça ne convaincrez
pas pourquoi ça ne te convaincre est pas
alors que tu essayes de mettre quelque
chose en place pour essayer en fait t'as
les marchés pas du tout une démarche d
essayer d'avoir tort et si tu ne fais ça
que pour essayer de te donner raison
tout ce cheminement la savoir comment
non pas comment les gens sont venus à
avoir ce préjugé mais aussi comment il
pourrait qu'est ce qui pourrait les
amener en une fois en deux fois à court
à londres à moyen ou à long terme à l'
déconstruire lassé des choses qu'il faut
on sait qu'il faut mettre sur le tapis
face à des gens alors dans des
discussions courante on a l'impression
qu'on ne sait pas possible de mettre
saxe et la discussion à la machine à
café on veut pas être dans cette
démarche qu' il faut réserver sa des cas
très particuliers à des débats de haute
tenue alors premièrement oui en tout cas
on peut le faire dans des beaux débats
et notamment quand il ya des gens qui
rentrent dans des sectes qui sont dans
un mouvement sectaire
vous allez dès que vous voulez des
ambrits grade ou dans des croyances qui
commence à avoir des conséquences
mauvaise pour les conseillers des gens
qui ont des croyances a pas de
conséquences s'il arrêtait les emmerder
mais si ça peut avoir potentiellement
des conséquences négatives et que vous
avez vraiment quoi selon vous je voulais
rentrer dans ce dialogue
ça peut être une stratégie par si ça
peut contribuer être l'une des
stratégies qui potentiellement peut
avoir un effet positif donc ça peut voir
le coup d'essayer de l'abonné puisse
avoue s'apprend pas laisser d'autres
personnes à essayer d'avancer avec
d'autres stratégies
bon voilà mais je défends quand même
l'idée que d'avoir dans un coin de sa
tête que ces concepts ces notions là
c'est ce rapport à l'autre là ce rapport
à là qu est ce qui a amené la personne
voir ce qu'elles croient et pas
seulement dont l'absolu et année
commence et les gens qui y croient ont
reçu une information vaincu ces deux
choses à différencier moi mon gros
boulot c'est vraiment la part de
journalistes qui le premier a mis sur le
marché cette idée et à tous les styles
tout mis en oeuvre pour essayer de se
donner tort lien ça c'est mon boulot
mais je dois intégrer tout le reste sur
comment pourquoi les gens croient ce
mois et pourquoi ils ont cet a priori et
pourquoi quand je m'adresse à eux à quoi
je me confronte
et bien tout ce qu'on vient de dire
toutes les nuances qu'on a dit ah ouais
penser avec bienveillance sur les
conséquences que ça aura accès il faut
les avoir et les intégrer pour que petit
à petit c'est un fils dans les mots
qu'on emploie dans le pont qu'on emploie
dans le rythme qu'on accorde à la
discussion
lorsque la discussion s'envenime de pas
avait claqué la porte il dira elle te
sens tu es trop con c'est aussi parce
qu'en fait on sème des petites graines
et l'autre c'est mon nouveau déprimé
mais sinon qu'on est quand même qu'on
est vraiment fait tout le boulot
derrière qu'on est vraiment évaluer les
données que la personne ça ça vous est
pas fait ce travail est persuadé que
qu'on l'a pas fait kallas préjugés à
notre égard eh ben il va falloir
intégrer ça dans toute notre attitude
dans tout notre rapport à l'autre
et quand on est médiateur scientifique
c'est hyper compliqué parce que doit
faire ça par rapport à tous les gens
qu'on a devant nous et quand on est
journaliste de vulgarisation c'est
encore plus compliqué parce qu'on sait
pas qui on a devant nous on a des
dizaines des centaines de lecteurs et
hélas il faut réfléchir notamment en
plus de tout ça à la effets positifs aux
effets négatifs implicite du média qu'on
emploie le fait de faire un une vidéo
sur internet le fait de présenter un
powerpoint lors d'une conférence devant
les gens juste le médium que tu utilises
le médium sens de marshall mcluhan tiers
le support de ton de ta communication le
fait d'utiliser un micro ou pas le fait
d'utiliser un powerpoint ou pas le fait
d'être sur une estrade ou pas tout ça
pour induire des choses à me dire ou es
ce que c'est vraiment le sud et ben en
fait quand tu fais un travail de
médiation oui la mise en page un impact
fallu faire des petites blagues garde
intactes les revenants vraiment au
médium vous donc le support de comédiens
l'objet des tice qui sert de vecteur au
message les gens qui les vulgarisateurs
qui utilisent la vidéo huaqiang ou tiff
qui était vidéaste pendant nombreuses
années et ben faut avoir conscience de
tout ce que ça comme effets positifs
comme effet négatif ça d un effet
positif quelques tu peux y avoir accès
quand tu veux tu peux la partager plus
facilement tu peut la partager avec les
gens qui ont des difficultés à lire qui
ont perdu l'habitude de lire qui
n'aiment pas lire qui ont besoin
d'accéder à cette information dans un
contexte où elles ne pourront pas ligne
inversement on a des gens qui vont
considérer que parce que c'est une vidéo
que ça une connotation particulière ce
support dans le monde il ya un an mais
ça ne peut pas être sérieux parce que
c'est une vidéo
savoir quand tu décides de communiquer
aux autres d'échanger de faire diffuser
pas pensé par ce support là là on le
fait avec un podcast ça a un sens de le
faire avec un podcast et et depuis tout
à l'heure je faisais des gestes et il ya
des chemins en fait il faudrait il
faudrait qu'on ait anticipé dans notre
discussion le fait d'avoir utilisé ce
support en particulier le fait que je
parle plaint beaucoup énormément plaint
trop fort et que je te laisse pas faire
des relances complique
l'audition enfin le lard et c'est en
gros que la capacité des auditeurs a
vraiment tout suivre parce que si jamais
on était filmé et là on est allongé sur
des dynamiques on est à la cool eh bien
peut-être que nos regards notre
incompréhension la moue de florian tu es
sûr de vouloir dire ce que dira la part
dont la rend le sujet plus
compréhensible intégré tout ça c'est
aussi hyper important je fais de la vers
nation quand je fais un article je me
dis que les gens qui sont derrière moi
qu'ils vont bien d'articles peut-être
pas jusqu'au bout ils vont structurer la
pensée je dois qu'on anticipée doit
avoir des préjugés sur leurs préjugés et
ben en fait c'est un travail énorme à sa
demande des années de plantage des
années à faire des articles que tu crois
être bon et bien pensé et qui sont mal
pensé ça c'est possible mais ça demande
aussi à une volonté de corriger une
volonté de faire mieux ton métier
volonté de mieux débattre une volonté de
mieux créer une volonté de mieux
vulgariser avec toujours la certitude
que tu fais le mieux que tu peux mais
sachant que le mieux que tu peux c'est
ce problème pas le plus optimal et tout
laissait aussi l'opportunité d'avoir
fait de la merde quoi j'avais pendant
mes mes études de journalisme et de
communication scientifique
j'ai fait deux mémoires le mémoire de
mai
is et master 1 et un mémoire de master 2
le mémoire de le premier mineur il a une
histoire rigolote
on en parlera ou pas de deuxième pause
et c'était la communication
interculturelle pour le développement
technique en asie du sud est
je vais très particulier c'est voilà
comment est ce que tu parles de deux
russes deux technologies pour enrôler
filtre alors je vais la simplifier mais
comment tu parles des filtres à eau
comment table tu permets un paysan au
cambodge fabriquer un filtre à eau
efficace d'une façon qui créa la faute
issus du soit utile pérenne et qui
ferait pas une dépendance à des
ressources étrangers enfin voilà comment
tu fais des choses qui vont être utiles
pas avoir d'impact trop mauvais voilà
que ça va pas détruire le tissu social
autour il ya des frites la plein de
questions hyper intéressantes sur quand
tu mets une pompe à eau ou qu'est-ce que
cela pas plus d'effets négatifs que deux
mais bon voilà
et surtout si tu veux transmettre une
technique parce que de france mais des
techniques locales des techniques et
étrangères vahland étrangères autant
historiquement que géographiquement
vraiment à nos questions qui sont posées
là dessus dans ce travail là j'étais
allé voir plein des ong françaises ou
non et je leur ai demandé c'est quoi ce
que vous faites pour être une stratégie
de comment vous sonder les cultures et
les représentations des autres parce que
lorsque vous transmettez quelque chose
est sûre qu'ils en ont bien besoin qu'il
venait d'équations entre leurs besoins
réels et votre proposition est est ce
que vous anticipez les conséquences
négatives de ce que vous leur proposez
bon voilà mais surtout est ce que mon
nom est venu à la question est ce qu'il
vous arrive est de communiquer de vous
planter quoi il ya une ong mais le
président d'une ong qui m'avait dit nous
pendant une ong de médecins
à ces petites petites structures ni nous
pendant dix ans
on est allé dans les pays on a fait les
campagnes de vaccination on a fait la
merde et je pense que certains pour un
loup jugée presque pour un crime contre
l'humanité tellement on a fait de la
merde je peux écrire ça dans mon mémoire
alors je vous explique pourquoi et après
vous verrez si vous l'écrivez mais il
était un cri du coeur lourd et parce
qu'en fait ils étaient contents qu'on
l'interview sur cette histoire de son
nom est levé ninon pendant des années on
était dans les villages et où on leur
posait des pompes à eau alors posé les
matchs alors c'était par n'est pas des
pompes à eau en l'occurrence là je je me
raconte je mélange désirant utiliser des
campagnes de vaccination on allait faire
des campagnes de vaccination et puis les
gens ils voulaient pas de nos campagnes
de vaccination alors on essaie de leur
faire comprendre que c'était bien et
puis on vacciner des gens pas beaucoup
bref ça pendant dix ans et puis quand on
arrivait quand on note nos stratégies
c'était des stratégies pour les aider à
avoir accès à des ressources baron dire
enfin des gens qui veulent avoir accès à
des ressources alors donné que cette
version se barrer
je revenais trois ans plus tard à qui on
fait que le projet avait capoté et puis
un jour il s'est passé quelque chose
alors je te donnerai tous les détails je
vous mettrai sur mon blog les détails
son histoire qui voilà qui est riche et
les détails de cette histoire sont aussi
intéressants mais ils sont dans leur
jeep
après une journée où ils ont proposé de
faire la vaccination qui rien y voit une
foule une foule s'agglutine est quelque
part sur une plaine sur une colline plus
rapportent et demandant qu'est ce qui se
passe c'est la fête du village c'est la
fête de quoi tant il peut pas une
vaccination on vient tous ces merdes
noël quand on vous propose une campagne
de vaccination vous nous snober
et c'est qui l'association qui fait ça
et alors c'est vétérinaires sans
frontières quoi ah bah oui les bêtes
c'est important monsieur 1 parce que si
on les vaccinent pas on voit bien
qu'elle meure et si elle meurt nous
comble rossi quoi
question et son nid en fait l'énergie et
l'argent qui mettait il le mettait dans
sauver des gens arrivent la verbaliser
et ses confrères avec qui j'avais j'ai
pu dicter ont verbalisé un petit peu de
façon je grossis le trait de ce qu'ils
m'ont dit oh on empêche les gens de
mourir et donc en gros la famille avec
cinq personnes eh bien s'ils avaient été
4 soit été mieux presque quoi dans la
situation où ils sont c'est triste à
dire mais de les aider à empêcher les
maladies d'emporter les ceux qui vont
ils font tellement souffrir
finalement si l'on une vache à partager
à 5h à partager à 4 passes si cynique de
dire ça mais et c voilà il ne pensait
pas à lui considère évidemment pas que
c'était une mauvaise chose de sauver les
gens mais en vrai je pense qu'elle veut
dire sur pas complètement mais d'un
point de vue de dans l'altruisme
efficace de comment tu peux essayer
faire le bien de façon la plus efficace
il dit si les ressources qu'on avait mis
en place pour que la famille survit
grâce à la vaccination les a émis pour
que c'est plus de bétail qui survivent
peut-être qu'ils auraient choqué des
maladies qui me mais c'est le deuxième
temps quoi entre permettre à tout le
monde de ne pas mourir de dénutrition
c'est quand même plus fréquent aussi que
de ne pas mourir de de telles maladies
juste en termes de fréquence
d'exposition d'avoir une vision un peu
plus globale le l'image
elles sont dix en fait on s'est planté
on n'a pas pensé à ça on n'a pas pensé
aux conséquences de nos actes ah et bien
tout ça c'est des choses qu'on doit à
l'échelle du diaries ateurs est celle de
toute personne qui essayait d'en avoir
un impact sur le monde qui croient
positif à chaque fois l'excès de
diffuser des connaissances diffuser la
bonne parole sur les vaccins en fait les
gens qu'il considérait pas que les
vaccins étaient mauvais ou au gabon mais
où ils ont mis beaucoup d'énergie et
c'est de se battre pour faire comprendre
que l'élection était bon alors que les
gens ici
il était d'accord déjà mais il n'avait
pas passé les coups de sonde
ce coup de sonde la cua donc voilà ça me
pose beaucoup de questions aujourd'hui
encore dans ma pratique
à quoi ça sert de faire un article sur
quoi ça sert de passer du temps à
vulgariser ce concept qu'en fait je
perdrais beaucoup l'énergie que je passe
à vulgariser cet article sur ce
médicament qui est pas encore au point
si je le passe à vulgariser des des
notions de statistiques
eh ben je ferai plus de bien plus tard
il voit là je pense que les
vulgarisateurs doivent intégrer
comprendre l'impact de leur média
l'impact de leurs pratiques
les conséquences de ces déçus de 12,82
de cerveau disponible qui prennent aux
gens quoi tout ça c'est important dans
nos pratiques
je reviens à nouveau sur ce fait de de
doussain décide amener les gens à
réfléchir à pourquoi ce qui pour ceux
qui pensent donc si on me remet dans le
droit dans le droit chemin inverse à six
mois là aussi c'était encore sur
certains points étaient déjà remontés
nous fait mais ce que tu avais parlé un
peu de cet aspect de ses deux jambes
dans les progrès ce qu'ils pensent ce
qu'ils pensent en mission de le piéger
non mais c'est ça qui sépare un piège
genre d'homme imaginaire beaucoup de
gens font ça will par ailleurs et je
pense que c'est très très mal et en fait
si on peut vraiment faire ça tu as sont
bienveillantes et essayer de d'amener
les gens à mieux comprendre pourquoi est
ce qu'ils pensent qu'ils pensaient du
coup les amener à mieux réfléchir
si vous pensez qu est-ce qui devrait du
combiné français je pense même qu'il
faut fit si tu as we d'être malhonnête
cité tendance incita pour cerveau dira
ce serait quand même
enfin je veux utiliser cette voie et que
tu as conscience que tu le fais ça vaut
le coup de le verbaliser tu dit écoute
heures deux directrices mans j'ai envie
de te poser une question mais je sais
quand la pause en jeu pourrait re ya
peut-être une part d'au moins qu'il ya
une une mauvaise intention j'ai envie de
te demander c'est quoi la chose
décisives quitte à amener à penser et
dire en fait même si on en arrive à donc
on verra aussi que toutes les questions
sont purement de bienveillance pas
facile mais le truc c'est que parmi les
gens qui compte qu'on sait s'interroge
sur pourquoi est-ce qu'ils débattent
mais pourquoi si les battre bah y'en a
qui le font avec 7,7 intentions arrive
dans leur esprit quoi tu te dis ah quand
même moi j'ai envie de le clouer le bec
à mon beau-frère qui à chaque fois aux
10 des annonceurs tri conneries sur
l'europe at il dit sur sa vision
essentialiste du monde sur tel sujet je
vous ai dû clouer le bec
j'ai envie de lui de lui faire un gros
doute dans sa gueule pour qu'ils y
réfléchissent à deux fois la prochaine
fois qu'ils balancent cela est donc
temps vide il ya des gens qui même s'il
aimerait être bienveillant la is wrong
et bien en fonction de la personne afin
qu'ils ont en fonction du contexte
ouais à prendre petit à petit a changé
de braquet et d'avoir cette attention
bienveillante et leurs intentions c'est
super difficile mais je pense que c'est
c'est un gain énorme face on arrive à
être bien plus bienveillant dans ses
questionnements
oui tu te lèves sûr et en plus on peut
du coup trouver du pain ou devra
beaucoup de plaisir enfin si notre but
c'est que la personne réfléchissent
mieux on trouvera beaucoup plus de
plaisir au moment où elle se
questionnera elle-même et réfléchira et
consentir à un progrès de sa part mais
après les gens qui vont répondre ouais
mais il ya des gens là je les suis allé
au contact je suis allée frontale et je
les piéger pour l'amener à avoir des
doutes
pour vraiment qu'elle se dit sa mère
tape et raison puis sont venues
longtemps après les faits mais en fait
tu avais raison
tu vois il n'y a pas besoin de faire ok
peut-être que les gens que ça peut être
une stratégie efficace mais il faut se
dire pour qui on le fait aussi et
l'absolu la douleur imaginons qu'on
dirait une personne pourquoi est-ce que
cette personne elle vous importe autant
web ce mon beau frère il me fait chier
parce que mais au delà de ça c'est aussi
vous c'est un travail sur nous mêmes le
travail d'esprit critique
il ya plusieurs choses dans l'esprit
critique moi j'ai une on va dire que
dans mon état de ma réflexion sur
l'esprit critique sur la pensée critique
sur ce que je fais j'ai une maxime qui
vient de plus en plus en tête de plus en
plus souvent en tête qui veut qui veut
dire ce que j'ai envie de lui faire dire
qui est plus il ya d'esprit critique mme
yade pour ses critiques
voilà une phrase oh mais qu'est ce que
tu veux dire par là là en vrai elle veut
rien dire a priori donc c'est un mauvais
slogan mais elle veut dire que plus les
notions basiques de l'esprit critique
plus le l'esprit critique est un terme à
la mode
plus les gens en fait l'utilisent comme
un outil pratique ils utilisent des
outils d'esprit critique pour débattre
mais ils n'ont pas une réflexion et non
pas d'esprit critique sur l'esprit
critique ils n'ont pas une vision sur
pourquoi ils font ça et c'est ça que je
me sens vide alors je sais que c'est pas
ça qu'on conventionnellement on appelle
la pensée critique là le temps de la
discussion je vais dire que c'est ça
accordez moi je pourrais l'appeler
autrement mais je vais l'appeler ça la
pensée critique et plus l'esprit
critique est un mode plus regarder les
gens qui font de la vulgarisation de
l'esprit critique plus il ya des
bouquins il ya des chaires de recherche
et ses bas j'ai pas l'impression que
j'ai même l'impression que la réflexion
philosophique
les réflexions épistémologiques
réflexion sur la façon de le média
d'utiliser les supports des médias pour
en parler si on compte sur eux qu'est ce
que ça nous apporte à nous mêmes en quoi
ça nous grandit pourquoi est-ce qu'on
fait ça ou pour ce nouveau grand dit
pourquoi ça ne grandit pas enfin va
juste section centré sur à quoi ça sert
tout ça est ce qu'on pourrait inventer
comme il ya le judo le kyudo la voie du
tir à l'arc et pourrait que l'esprit
critique de la voix pour être un
meilleur être humain est ce que est ce
que c'est là une bonne voie est-ce qu'on
ne vient pas est ce que finalement ce
n'est pas une bonne façon de devenir un
sale connard arrogant que de faire
l'esprit critique au contraire est ce
que c'est si on pousse le truc jusqu'au
bout on l'esprit critique ce serait une
sorte de pyramide à 64 étages et plus
graves et les étages la plus tu as une
humidité espiègle et bienveillant de
de ce client qui sont pas tus tillon un
autre parcours de vivre notre parcours
de penser et que et que tu es nerveux
quand yves que tu as une saine colère
comme disait ségolène royal face à des
vrais scandales mais que tu te tue monte
pas dans les tours pour rien et que face
à des personnes qui ont agi ce qu'ils
ont un impact négatif sur sur d autres
qui les en brigades dans des choses
dangereuses et ben tu sais qui a
réfléchi
tu as pris du recul sur comment exprimer
vis-à-vis de ouf vis-à-vis de ceux qui
l'écoutent pour amener un max une
proportion maximum de gens à long terme
a1 ce qui est de moins d'impact négatif
pour toutes cette réflexion métal mais
tam et assure sur pourquoi on fait tout
ça elles existent pel et peut verbaliser
elle est peu formalisés je dis pas que
plein de gens n'ont pas quand jean
laffon bien leur coin jean même qui
théorisent dessus qui publie dessus par
contre elle et peut diffuser ou allez
pas assez diffusé et aujourd'hui voilà
alors qu'il ya plein de vulgarisateur
qui se mettent sur le créneau de
l'esprit critique
moi je suis un julien bajeux jeu meti je
sais pas si c'est pas dans ma vie ou
twitter ou un truc qui veut dire la même
chose mais vulgarisateur esprit critique
voilà il faut vraiment un moment que ça
devienne un enjeu du réflexion avec des
blogueurs esprit critique gens parlent
certains on en parle on se prend toutes
les deux semaines une heure deux heures
où la conversation daisy là dessus et où
on se pose ces questions n'ont pas su
enfin sur à quoi ça sert et pourquoi et
surtout comment faire et quand je vois
des gens dire on va mettre sur le tapis
on va mettre sur le tapis le fait que
l'homéopathie c'est une pseudo médecine
et comment à faire en sorte que le fait
de le mettre sur le tapis ça a un effet
positif sur le monde
moi j'en ai dans mon travail de
journaliste en santé je vous paie pas
une occasion pertinente d'en parler il
ya eu plein d'occasions d'en parler de
l'aube de l'équpe de tel ou tel truc qui
en homéopathie vais pas débattre et les
tribus
enfin c'est de la flûte appartient à ce
grand domaine de trucs dont on sait
pertinemment que c'est faux et quand
j'avais une occasion pertinente de le
faire réfléchissez à comment bien le
faire et je voyais quand même que ça a
changé pas grand chose quoi ça a amené
quelques ajustements les stratégies que
gérer pour rendre le truc le plus utile
possible
c'était de dire ok peut-être que vous
allez vous voulez garder dans votre
esprit que l'homéopathie fonctionne ce
que ça vous y tenez convenait au moins
avec moi que c'est différent de ce qu'on
appelle la phytothérapie que c'est pas
pareil que nos histoires du l'essentiel
de l'aromathérapie tout ça c'est un truc
un peu à part avec une plaie théorie à
par derrière que vous connaissez ou pas
mais vous comprenez que ça appartient
pas aux mêmes champs tout à fait l'idée
globale sont diluées ça soigne même si
vous confondez ça avec la mitterie la
mithridatisation on est d'accord si ça
pouvait être sage est mon objectif
pourquoi plus tard on puisse continuer
le débat mais je savais bien que tout
cela n'avait pas d'impact dans l'eure
dans le monde
suffisant et j'ai discuté avec pas mal
de gens on m'a dit façon si ça doit
changer ça doit changer des principaux
responsables c'est à dire les médecins
qui sont complaisant vis-à-vis de leurs
confrères qu'ils brandissent le titre de
maupassant me l'a dit mais je parierais
certain nombre d'années et quand j'ai
écrit mon monde l'ag sortir un bouquin
en 2017 qui s'appelle santé sciences
wata doit-on tout gober qui est en fait
une manuelle d'esprit critique qui prend
le prétexte de l'information
scientifique pour réfléchir à comment
est ce qu'on sait ce qu on s'est posé
des questions de dépister beau poser des
questions et dialectique s'appelle
douter du douteux qui essayent de
vulgariser des questions de voilà deux
curseurs de vraisemblance de presque
rien sur le fait qu'il faut pas douter
de tout et que quand tu doutes il faut
réfléchir à thé à priori à tes impôts
servent à toutes ces questions là
j'essaie de les vulgariser avec tout ce
recul qui étaient de ma pratique de
vulgarisateur de journalistes et quand
je suis arrivé au chapitre où je vous
parlais du que je parlais du cas
particulier
alors je parle pas que de la médecine
nick young des sciences quand je suis
arrivé au cas de la médecine vu que
c'était dans le titre je parlais des
médecins je disais quand même je vois
parler de l'homéopathie on va parler des
machins mais les médecins
les l'ordre des médecins sayah de là
tant qu'ils font rien ça changera pas
quoi quand j'ai écrit ça je disais c'est
un petit peu un jeu un peu en train de
dire ça voyez vous j'ai écrit un
chapitre là dessus et tous ces trucs là
mais bon envahira je pisse dans un
violon en écrivant ce chapitre parce que
ça me changera pas paf quatre mois ou
cinq mois plus tard il ya des des via un
moment à force que des gens partout et
probablement une même réflexion que et
bien il s'est même raisonnement est venu
mais celle et chez les médecins et d
israël qu à un moment où si on veut que
ça change ça ne peut venir que de nous
pourquoi venir que de nous parce qu'un
médecin comme il se penser dans les
reprises les représentations que les
médecins vont de même beaucoup de
médecins pensent qu'ils sont des
scientifiques soir réfute qui sont les
copains rejette l'élection des
scientifiques qui disent nous sommes
nous pratiquons un art une sorte d'
artisanale qui est celui de soigner les
patients mais nous suivons une dans nos
diagnostics une méthode qui est une
méthode de déductions qui est une
méthode scientifique ou un mac estime
que l on fait des études scientifiques
pour être médecin dans qu'ils sont
scientifiques et donc tout ce qui fait
au tout ce qu'on leur a appris dans
leurs études son voeu est valide et
comme tout ce qu'ils ont appris dans
leur étude est valide bailly seront une
ils sont très bien placée pour porter la
parole des sciences de la science avec
un grand s de la science médicale en
faisant mon parenthèse ans il voulait
des sources pour montrer à quel point il
ya des idées reçues de chez les médecins
voilà vous référer au chapitre 9 du
bouquin c'est comment au fil des études
ce que les étudiants apprennent ils des
apprennent et au fur et à mesure même
s'ils sont toujours dans le cursus et se
déforment certaines représentations qui
vont après m'être dans leur pratique qui
s'impose un peu des questions pour pour
parler de santé rien ne vaut un médecin
mais tous les médecins vinson qui se
croient à jour ne le sont pas quoi donc
il est plus probable d'avoir une
information correcte de la part de santé
de la part d'un médecin mais c'est pas
parce que un médecin dit quelque chose
que si forcément correct bref
toujours est il que cette idée que ça ne
peut venir que d'eux parce que des
médecins par leur médecin et un
journaliste scientifique vulgarisateur
une communauté de vulgarisateur une
communauté de deux chercheurs ce qui des
gens qui ont bossé sur sur l'homéopathie
ont fait des expériences en double avec
en dessert marx et à eybens ignorons à
l'oreille ils n'auront pas duré
ils seront vus comme n'appartenant pas à
la sphère des gens qui sont ceux qui
sont ces scientifiques qui en plus sont
sur le terrain ils ont un savoir a été
validée sinon je crois par leur école de
médecine par dix et des enseignants qui
sont des gens qui ont le recul de leur
âge et le recul de leur pratique alors
ne venez pas nous dire que l'homéopathie
ça marche pas quoi mais si jamais ça
vient de l'intérieur deux médecins qui
en fait le même cursus
les médecins peuvent venir écoutez nous
on a fait le même cheminement que toi on
a fait les mêmes cours on a peut-être eu
les mêmes profs sauf que au lieu à l'est
du dans le cours d'eau mais au pâtis là
dans la spécialisation
on a suivi d'autres cursus et puis on a
passé un peu plus de temps à vérifier
les stats etc
je caricature en rien en tout cas juste
imaginer que donc nous on est du même
comme toi on est de la même école que
toi on est de la même promo que toi et à
une spécialisation près nous on pense
que tu dis la meilleure de quoi comme
rosie soulage aussi parce qu'on est du
même on est de la même classe
la même année on a comment ça se fait
qu'on n'arrive pas la même conclusion
quoi et comment ça se fait que tu alors
que le code de déontologie des médecins
nous en a voilà on a un code de
déontologie dans le code de santé
publique et il dit qu'on n'a pas le
droit de de proposer à nos patients des
traitements suffisent insuffisamment
éprouvé oui mais l'homéopathie
suffisamment éprouvés banon nous nous
ont dit le contraire dialogue avec nous
quoi et bien c'est par eux que est
directement parce que ça pouvait faire
des changements et on a vu au fil d'un
an et demi deux et ça tu vois le fait
d'avoir conscience que mettre sur le
tapis des problématiques dvd
des problématiques des secours un
partisan du champ de l'esprit critique
du champ de la critique des des fausses
croyances des ne pas réfléchir à quelle
est la meilleure façon de le faire venir
finalement tous les articles
peut-être que le seul le seul truc utile
que j'ai fait ça a été d'être d'avoir
été l'une des des voix une voix parmi
eux être des milliers d'autres à voir
quand il dire ça serait bien que les
médecins un jour il le fasse ça serait
bien que et je sais peut-être quelqu'un
qui l'a dit six mois avant qui a
provoqué le truc peut-être que c'est
juste la chorale qui a fait ça toujours
est il que ce qui pouvait avoir un effet
a eu un effet quand des gens font
constat que le journalisme scientifique
connaît une crise que la le traitement
des sciences dans les médias en 2019
il est par formidable ce qui est un peu
voilà l'objet et enfin le locker dans
mon travail de journaliste et de
vulgarisation
c'est mon support de mon objet d'étude
et mon objet prétexte quand je veux
parler d'esprit critique en a qui disent
allons enquêter sur les ovnis d'autres à
l'enquêté sur sur les sourciers moi je
dis bah allons enquêter sur les
informations colportées par les
journalistes et finalement on est plus
souvent confrontés à une information
colportée par journalistes que tu as un
sourcier donc coaching c'est un objet
cool quoi dire prenant le journal et
essayons de voir s'il ya pas des trucs
complètement fou et est-ce qu'on ne
pourrait pas et quand il ya un article
dit oui l'homéopathie ça marche
remontons le fils de ça et finalement on
arrive au même raisonnement ayant même
exemple pour expliquer pourquoi les
journalistes font mal leur boulot en
rond on en revient souvent à parler de
cas où ils ont colporté des choses
fausses sur les ovni ou des choses
fausses sur les c'est pour ça que c'est
rigolo et que tous ceux de paris de tous
ces sujets connexes et de voilà bref
toujours est il que si tu veux faire
changer le journalisme aujourd'hui elle
parle de science et de santé il ya ça ça
va pas ça ne va pas
j'ai plein de confrères formidable j'ai
des étudiants que j'ai formés qui sont
mais ils ont non seulement ils ont été
formés à la badine par mois parce que
quand je forme les étudiants jeu je fais
jv cachant dans le jeu c'est de leur
dire tout ce qui m'a manqué et puis de
trouver des stratégies pour que qui s'en
souviennent de quoi je les pièges je
suis un prof très sournois mais j'essaie
de faire des choses dont je pense que ça
avoir un effet dans l'information
ils ont été avec plein d'autres profs
qui sont ils sont beaucoup plus
longtemps avec moi et voilà bon bref
et puis surtout ils ont un jeu mais ce
qui fait qu'ils ont encore toutes leurs
illusions et la volonté de changement et
donc il ya peu il ya tous où des
milliers d'autres les sur formé par
d'autres gens encore plus plus malins
encore plus stratège avec encore plus de
réflexion sur le bon journalisme
scientifique que je pourrai jamais en
avoir
et donc voilà on il ya des délits gion
de bons journalistes scientifiques et
puis le problème c'est que dans les
grandes rédactions n'y a pas que ça il
ya aussi des légions et des cordes et
des réunions de cordes et des century de
gens à qui on a demandé de bosser sur
les sciences
alors qu'ils n'ont pas fait de travail
sur eux mêmes qui travaillent on a un
peu travaillé je parlais tout à l'heure
donc ce problème il existe ce problème
je le dénonce et j'essaye de l'inde et
de dénoncer avec des cas particuliers il
ya les problèmes des plagiats tous les
problèmes tiff
il ya des problèmes économiques c'est
vraiment systémique à tout concourt à ce
que ça soit à satisfaisant que le grand
public qui ne lit pas les revues
spécialisées ou des revues qui lisent
des revues spécialisées qu'ils ont
achetés dans le vent quand ils vont au
relais relais de du libraire chez le
marchand de journaux
et bien il y en allant chez oreillons
science ils tombent sur des passes qui
veulent un truc un peu plus spécialisés
ils tombent sur des choses fausses
avec des représentations fausses bon
tout ça ça yaya il ya un problème
les multis causal la formation la
formation continue nos histoires de
tache aveugle et puis plein plein plein
d'autres choses
la question économique des questions de
parrainage au sein des rédactions
actions de structuration des rédactions
d'où tu peux être les trois meilleurs
journalistes scientifiques de la planète
même rédaction a vécu relecteurs ou un
secrétaire de rédaction qu'elle arrive à
des défunts qui va prendre les décisions
décisives pour la mise en page est
maintenu que l'on peut anéantir le train
ce travail qui même s'il a cette chaîne
là elle est parfaite
bar le rédacteur en chef du journal peu
à infléchir avec des financements avec
des choses une paire plein de raisons
d'expliquer pourquoi ça va pas
eh bien je pense que il ya plein de
façons d'essayer de changer le cet état
de fait qui sont inefficaces ou
contreproductives et qui ne vont que
renforcer le voilà pour le coup c'est
vraiment des coups d'épée dans l'eau
et ça ça me serait intéressant que que
les gens qui qui constate que le monde
du journalisme scientifique hall porte
parfois des choses un peu un peu
douteuse voire même carrément carrément
craignos et ben sahar est besoin de la
toque de gueuler sur le premier
journaliste venu et écris tu as écrit un
article pour y à leurs yeux et qui vont
le harceler sur twitter ils vont lui
tomber dessus en lisant là qu'ils vont
développer une sorte de parfois même de
raisonnement assez complotistes sur oued
de stations dans ce journal
vous faites ça parce que est ce que vous
êtes
tu sais pas moi y'a des gens qui sont
pas contents parce qu'il ya des
journalistes qui font des raccourcis sûr
il ya des copains qui va écrire un
article sur au moins dans le bio n'est
pas de pesticides par exemple alors
qu'il existe des pesticides utilisant le
bio et vont l'attaquer en grève cette
nuit vous avez même se met même pas
qu'il ya pas des pesticides dans le bios
état sur twitter
besson twittos ce qu'ils vont dire a dit
connaissez rien comment vous pouvez vous
être journaliste
les autres tweets plus ou moins polis et
puis bah peut-être que la personne
effectivement elle a travaillé sur ces
idées reçues
peut-être qu'elle le sait très bien et
elle ne fait pas pour tromper mais
qu'elle considère comme implicite que
les pesticides qui ne sont pas produits
à la chaîne à partir de un processus de
synthèse ou ne pas du tout le même
statut et devrait parler à 12 sas et il
y en a qu'on devrait appeler pesticides
et doc on devrait appeler j'ai pas on
devrait peut-être selon lui le et
peut-être ils ont des raisons et
peut-être même des bonnes raisons de
croire qu'il faudrait l'appeler d'un
autre nom est donc là peut-être que lui
travaille représentation du public et 10
la dent on sait très bien où ça et
d'ailleurs regardez dans l'écrit plein
d'articles ont dit ces produits utilisés
pour pour protéger les cultures dans le
bio et puis on a employé des mots
pesticides dedans et on a précisé qu'ils
étaient passés en tête et puis à ceux
qui jouent sur cette ambiguïté sciemment
qui sont là pour tromper le public qui
font croire qu'il n'y a pas de pas de
loup derrière leur façon de communiquer
il faut arriver sur ces sujets c'est de
comprendre quelle est l'intention
essayer de se demander vu que ya déjà
des centaines d'articles dans ce temps
là dans ce genre là bas est ce que est
ce que c'est un combat digne d'intérêt
est ce que taper sur ce journaliste
sahara intéresse que lui donner l'info
et puis direct au top c'est bon l'info a
été donné on voit que l'info était
donnée donc nous qui voulons pour
participer à une coupe à l'éducation
scientifique des journalistes on va
arrêter de reposter trois fois les miens
est-ce qu'il n'y aurait pas une autre
façon de s'adresser à lui est ce que est
ce que est ce qu'on en fait il faudrait
pas juste bas nous produire des vidéos
et puis que qui sont destinés un circuit
parallèle de l'information au public
pour leur dire voilà bon il ya des
longues qui l'emploie qui emploie le mot
pestis pesticides en prétendant qu'il
n'a pas dans le bio mais juste pour
votre info certains savent très bien que
des pistes utilisées utilisé dans le bio
mais l'emploi
en supposant que qu'on parle pas de la
même chose si tu veux vraiment donné
cette information et qui juge pertinente
de la mettre sur le marché des
connaissances away arrêté de faim faut
peut-être pas caricaturer la pensée des
journalistes la pensée des journalistes
qui emploient ces mots là et puis
surtout arrêter d'imaginer que c'est en
en balançant des tweets pour taper sur
les landri souffre
ouais que costa va changer quoi que ce
soit alors moi j'ai essayé de développer
des stratégies en pas sur le truc du bio
les histoires de l'agriculture
d'environnement géraud en proportion pas
beaucoup écrit là-dessus parce que
d'autres le font en telligent un membre
du coup moi il est il ya d'autres enjeux
il ya d'autres choses qui m'intéressent
plus en fait et qui me semble encore
plus importante à tord ou à raison mais
donc sur les sujets qui m'intéressent
sur les fausses représentations qui nous
pose problème et qui pose question et je
vois qu elles sont pertinentes questions
autour du placebo par exemple y en a ici
qui emploie le mot placebo et qui vont
écrire des articles entiers ans avec une
fausse idée de ce que c'est que le
placebo
je me suis dit je vais faire changer les
choses de l'intérieur je vais en tant
que journaliste faire une critique de
journalistes et l'adresser à mes pairs
adressé m'adresser aux futurs
journalistes écrire des bouquins qui
font peut pas être achetée par le groupe
big mais qui seront dans l'autre les
mains de journalistes
et puis je vais leur adresser en leur
disant où ils vont leur être adressés je
sais qu'ils vont leur être adressés tôt
ou tard leur dire vous avez un chapitre
entier sur les fausses représentations
et le cas particulier des prix c'est
celui du placebo et vous allez voir que
c'est parce que vous croyez
et puis je vais être malin je vais même
mettre ce bout de mon bouquin dans en
libre accès parce que je sais que ça
c'est le point sur lequel je veux
travailler et que des gens vont
l'envoyer à des journalistes les gens
vont envoyer leurs copains leurs
collègues leurs confrères si moi je vais
pouvoir l'envoyer à des journalistes qui
maltraitent cette notion là je vais
l'envoyer de façon en privé leur disant
et coûteux je me suis j'ai longtemps
écrit des articles en partant d'un a
priori qui était faux un préjugé qui
était sur le placebo
en ayant beaucoup bossé dessus je suis
arrivé à d'autres compétitions
j'en ai fait une synthèse que j'ai
essayé de rendre accessible pour tous
dit peut-être que ce sera pas d'accord
avec mais je te laisse dans les mots que
j'emploie dans mon intention donc
l'heure à laquelle je vais transmettre
cette information
c'est pas de la manipulation assez juste
comment être efficace et comment être
pertinent et ça marche peut-être pas à
100% mais j'ai l'impression que ça
marche nous et surtout dans la façon
dont les structures et cet article pour
que ce soit à mon avis j'ai l'impression
je crois c'est ma croyance qu'il est
structurée d'une façon qui aide les gens
à en ail et à avoir envie d'aller plus
loin parce que je rebondis parfois sur
le lean l'idée reçue qui pourrait venir
tout de suite par l'enjeu dit dès le
début que les gens se croient souvent
que c'est quelque chose d'inexpliqué
alors que ça n'allait pas au moment où
il irait mais il nous parle de l eac
moi aussi je croyais que c'était une
explorer abou salah était donc nourrir
en permanence l'intérêt on rebondissant
sur ce que j'ai identifié la force de
des changes comme des choses qui popent
dans la tête et qui vont peut-être blocs
et à réflexion ouais mais de toute façon
c'est rien ne lie plus loin parce qu'on
va encore me dire la même chose
donc voila moi j'essaie que j'essayais
de faire changer les choses de
l'intérieur
en m'adressant aux journalistes en écran
en tant que journaliste d'une rédaction
qui faisait des chroniques à l'antenne à
gros argument d'autorité mais surtout
arguments corporatiste quoi d'essayer de
2 et bien je peux vous confirmer les
petits amis que ça n'a pas beaucoup
d'impact d'essayer de changer les choses
à ma taille avec la méthode que j'ai
employée
c'est un petit impact ça a des impacts
et les journalistes qui est qui j'ai
échangé et qu'il reste en échange
fortis a eu un impact
positif est que à qui en a on a
construit une réflexion aujourd'hui me
fait faire de la vulgarisation faire du
journalisme encore encore et toujours
différemment
et puis mais quand même la majorité il
ya des gens en off les gardiens qui
m'avait dit il ya j'étais invité à un
débat dans le débat s'est pas fait entre
avec un journaliste qui est pour des
raisons qui lui appartiennent à
suspicieux qui a vraiment l'impression
que que beaucoup de journalistes sont
menés à la baguette par des dix membres
du lobbying par des gens qui essayent
d'influencer la les articles des
journalistes à la marge subtilement
alors c'est courant quand on reçoit un
communiqué de presse c'est déjà une
façon d'essayer d'influencer on me dit
tiens voilà un sujet bon bref j'étais
invité à débattre avec un journaliste
réputé pour être suspicieux et parfois
un peu faim même pas 20 ans nelly
peut-être qu'il est suspicieux au delà
du raisonnable il à niveau de suspicion
et son détecteur de 2,2 gens qui sont
sous influence involontaire portée de
l'aube israël est un peu trop on y voit
un peu paranoïaque sur les bords et on
m'avait dit qu'il avait dit de moi qu'il
ait accepté de débattre parce que
j'étais probablement l'un des rares
journalistes à ne pas être aujourd'hui
donc voilà oui il est carrément
paranoïaque mais cette phrase pourquoi
est ce qu'ils m'avaient jugé comme ça
alors qu'on était probablement jamais
rentrant l'interaction l'un avec l'autre
c'est que déjà c'est dégueulasse pour
tous ceux qui sont pas vendus et pour
les tous ses confrères maintenant sa
rédaction qui ne sont pas meilleurs et
ce qui voulait dire de tout ce qu'on
essaie de me présenter comme un
contradicteur
ou pas comme un contradicteur mais comme
quelqu'un qui pourrait
ou parler de ces sujets d'une autre
façon le j'avais acquis une légitimité à
cessieu pourquoi parce que je suis
j'essaye d'être bienveillant rigoureux
ne pas prendre les gens pour des cons et
que quand j'ouvre ma gueule jeu j'essaye
de l'ouvrir non pas sur la base de mes a
priori mais sur la base d'un travail
préalable et que je sais reconnaître
quand j'ai tort je le fais je sais pas
j'ai j'ai mis six ans à trouver une
posture un peu équilibristes de 2,2
comment je m'exprime sur la place
publique c'est peut-être tout pourri
c'est peut-être mauvais en tout cas
voilà je suis aujourd'hui dans cette
réflexion dans cette démarche je suis
loin d'être efficace pertinent mais
malgré tout ça voilà je suis dans cet
état aujourd'hui de mon activité
professionnelle de journaliste
vulgarisateur ou de simplement
vulgarisateur je sais pas où j'en suis
un professionnel bon mais ça me pose un
problème que et des gens qui essayent
d'aller places publiques pour mener ces
combats sans avoir amorcé en apparence
en tout cas je prêche planète mais il me
semble que certain nombre d'entre eux
ont pas vraiment amorcé ce travail de
réflexion sur un même sur ce que c'est
que le monde du journalisme est sûre
revoilà gagner un capital crédibilité
sur le fait qu'ils sont là pour faire
évoluer les choses parce qu'il ya un
vrai problème est qu'il ya des
journalistes qui l'ont identifié
moi je pense que l'évolution du
journalisme viendra lorsque des
associations de danse qu'est le
journalisme scientifique où le
journaliste qui parle de science
changera le jour où des associations de
journalistes
frau c'est un petit monstre vert mais le
ménage dans leurs rangs où il y aura une
scission il y en a qui diront 'vous
bosser différemment et qu'ils auront une
légitimité de parler à leur corporation
et que et qui seront appuyés dans la
société civile par des gens qui auront
serons capable de vulgariser leurs
points de vue en s'étant posé des
questions sur ce qui se passe ce qui va
pas dans le journalisme scientifique et
qui se sont posés des questions
profondes
pourquoi ça va pas mais pas juste des
questions superficiel et je crois qu'on
en ait eu malheureusement là moi j'ai
fait des trucs ça n'a pas marché c'est
intéressant que mon retour d'expérience
sur ce qui n'a pas marché à soit
diffusée que quand on fait relire des
articles qui critiquent le journalisme
scientifique bas des pages du site écrit
ça sert à rien quoi c'est déjà tu te
trompe de combat tu te trompes de
diagnostic et puis et puis si tu essayes
de faire changer d'avis l'auteur se sert
à rien de l'écrire comme et puis ya des
choses que j'ai fait que je sais que ça
a eu un peu d'impact donc c'est
peut-être une piste
et voilà donc moi je suis s'il ya des
gens qui nous écoutent encore après
cette donc innocent ce jour à l'écouté
du poker et que j'ai envie de continuer
la réflexion sur le comment faire
évoluer le mâle journalisme comment
faire un peu moins de mal journalisme
réduire les situations de désinformation
de mes informations c'est à dire de
désinformation volontaire involontaire
de désinformation volontaire donc de mes
informations
voilà je suis disponible puisque jeunes
il faut qu'on se mette à plusieurs et
pourquoi cette pensée là cette pensée
critique sur le sur ce qui va pas là
d'un soir se développe quoi je sais pas
si j'ai référence un peu à la tribune
qui est sorti quelques joueurs on est
quoi l armée on est mimine juillet 2019
donc il ya une une tribune qui s'appelle
no fake sayoud qui était cosignée
français actuel par 400 personnes que
nous sommes ça continue à augmenter un
peu qu'ils appellent un peu
chaque appel à beaucoup de choses mais
on va dire en vo qui appelle à davantage
de rigueur scientifique dans le
journalisme
qu'est ce qu'ils sont ce ces tribunes
qu'est ce qui était fait qu'est-ce qui
était alors c'est compliqué d'en parler
à dents à plaindre et voilà je vais en
parler mais déjà je voulais pas signer
on m'a proposé de signer je ne vais pas
signer
on est là une une histoire cette tribune
qui est importante d'avoir avant même
d'en parler elle a été écrite par des
blogueurs des gens des journal est un
pas les journalistes
elle a été écrite par des des gens qui
au début de l'année 2019 ont été choqués
par lé une sorte de trop-plein de sorte
de ras-le-bol à propos de fans sur des
lunes émissions ou des émissions
je sais pas à quel point on fait la
généalogie de 7,2 cette tribune je la
perçois bien je la connais bien je crois
à bien la connaître mais et puis
peut-être que voilà que cette généalogie
est pas tout à fait juste comment dire
que peut être est ce qu'ils ont envie de
considérer que cette généalogie et
pertinente et jamal j'aime bien savoir
ce que les gens ont envie de dire de
leur propre travail et comment ils le
perçoivent eux mêmes alors je suis pas
rédacteur de cette preview de l'enjeu en
tout cas au début de l'année 2019 des
situations identifiés par des gens comme
des situations de mes informations
scientifiques les ont vraiment ça vous
saouler quoi ils sont 10 voilà nous il
faut faire quelque chose
nous on n'est pas des journalistes on y
ait des vulgarisateurs des blogueurs des
chercheurs les apprentis chercheurs des
thésards et la désinformation ça suffise
ont dit on va essayer de faire une
tribune sur le modèle en tout cas
inspiré par le succès de la tribune sur
les les médecines
les pratiques se présentant comme des
alternatives à la médecine dans les
colonies de l'ofec mais voilà et alors
je sais pas si c'est vrai que ça qui les
inquiète toujours et xbla ça s'inscrit
apparemment dans cette filiation et ils
écrivent ça et il ya pas mal de version
et ça intervient en plus à un moment
il ya des journalistes qui sur les
réseaux sociaux et mettent eux aussi des
critiques sur ouvrent leurs ressources
mais cette situation particulière
identifié comme une situation de mes
informations scientifiques qui à mon
avis ces journalistes qui sont
intervenus sur la place publique de
mauvaise façon
ils ont en début de l'année 2019 pour
ceux qui essayeront de revenir sur cette
moment de débat autour de qu'est ce qui
se passe dans le journalisme notamment
il ya eu un moment où une grande
critique l'honneur sur les réseaux
sociaux sur une émission de france 2 qui
parlait de l'agriculture de pesticides
ou j'ai eu quelque chose comme çà et là
les minéraux des faux seins
en tout cas moi de la façon de faire de
la de l'information scientifique
moi je pense qu'à une chose est à
critiquer sur cette pétition
les intervenants qui sont choisis la
façon de mettre en scène
l'information des critiques très
légitime existe d'ailleurs françois
toutes ces critiques qui ont été
formulées par par plein de gens est long
mais aussi plein d'autres critiques ont
été formulées étaient moins importants
j'étais moins pertinente était
secondaire quitter et puis à des
critiques fossat des critiques il faut
c'est en tout cas que je juge vraiment
pas pertinente et des contre-arguments
certaines allégations
cette émission qui étaient des arbitres
des contre arguments erronés quoi et là
il s'est passé quelque chose c'est qu'il
ya des journalistes donc ils sont
exposés pour dénoncer cette situation de
mes informations avec en faisant quelque
chose qui moi me semblait relever
également à certains titres est patent
mauvais travail d'un mauvais travail
d'effectuer un travail bâclé d'un
travail trop empressés voilà donc
toujours à interdire la news du fight et
est en tout cas moi si si j'avais dû
alors si j'avais eu si j'avais été dans
la controverse pour une raison x ou y
alors j'étais absolument pas dans
derrière mon écran au début de 50
c'était pendant que ça a été diffusé
et l'heure n'était pas en france je suis
revenue j'ai extrait le bordel mais je
me suis la façon si on veut faire une
critique constructive de ce qui a été
produit par des journalistes à ce moment
là qu'on a envie de leur faire
comprendre ce qui pourrait choquer un
point de vue des canons du journalisme
scientifique tels que moi je les conçois
bras florian qui essayent de développer
une réflexion et qui est peut-être tort
autour de ces questions à la hausse est
pas le moment d'en parler c'est le
bordel il ya des gens qui ont foutu le
bordel
et puis tout le monde sait ça monte ça a
monté un
toujours est il que voilà il ya des
cette tribune a aussi à mon avis est
aussi née d'un peut-être d'un désir de
soutenir les journalistes qui voudraient
leur viol à ce moment là et dire quand
même gens disent que leur gueule et il
n'arrive pas à établir le dialogue donc
les dialogues corpo entre la corporation
de l'efs les journalistes partis aux
journalistes l'organe dialogue inter
intra corporatisme fonctionne pas ben
nous on va dire ça suffit quoi est donc
un travail de rédaction à plusieurs
moments parce que parce que parce que je
suis écrit un bouquin sur le sujet on
m'a fait des des retours m'en dire on
est en train de préparer cette chronique
cette tribune voilà ce qu'on va dire
dedans il ya des notions que toi tu
définis comme étant déficit sisyphe pour
caractériser le journalisme scientifique
qui nourrissent notre réflexion sur
l'écriture de la tribune donc on est on
te propose d'y participer j'ai regardé
la tribune telle qu'elle se dessine et
elle m'a posé beaucoup de questions donc
on est au premier trimestre 2010 9
elle m'a posé beaucoup de questions dans
sa forme dans sa structure dans les
arguments qu'elle présente dans la
définition d'un on va dire en prenant un
peu de recul sur la whey la
représentation qu'elle donne à voir ou à
croire
deux des représentations comment est ce
que les auteurs auraient de ce que c'est
que la france discutait avec tel ou tel
contribuer de 20 de ses citoyens
désireux de produire cette tribune et je
m'aperçois que les idées qu'ils ont des
valeurs qu'ils défendent leur
épistémologie de comment les sciences se
font mais c'est un peu un pléonasme jean
fabrice et eléonore leur connaît la leur
leurs épistémologie leur philosophie
leurs connaissances en épistémologie
reconnaissance et l'ofii son on les
retrouve pas dans dans ce texte
et puis que en mettant les idées dans
cet ordre là même avec toutes les
précautions oratoires moyens un truc qui
me j'arrivais pas à mettre le doigt
dessus et je ne suis pas capable
aujourd'hui forcément de mettre le petit
je me suis bon et moi y'a un truc
timmins qui me pose question je crois
que la notion de typiquement voilà il
dans cette tribune dont tu parles il
présente des consensus zizola l'énergie
nucléaire serait poupart jeu là je sais
pas ce qu'il disait quelqu'un on
mettrait et en produisant peu de carbone
il faut à prétendre qu'elle est qu'elles
contribuent au réchauffement climatique
quoi en tout cas elle elle contribuerait
moins que les autres au réchauffement
climatique est une formulation a
retrouvé aujourd'hui aux caisses et
c'est pas fou le dire mais si vous dites
comme ça pensez à la place des gens qui
vous lisent ils vont avoir l'impression
que vous dites ça en occultant le reste
de tout le débat sur le sur l'énergie
nucléaire le retraitement des déchets
juste d'un point de vue politique
comment est-ce que tu as sur la la que
les centrales produite aujourd'hui
seront toujours aux figures entretenu
dans dix ans dans ras pendant 30 ans
dans 40 ans la citation exacte c'est
l'énergie nucléaire est une technologie
à faible émission de co2 tu es peut
contribuer à la lutte contre le
changement climatique
voilà et bien cette affirmation là
on va dire que on peut considérer que l
est pas faux sang de soi mais elle
allait charger de plein de plusieurs
implicite les charges et d'implicite si
on a l'impression qu'elle est écrite
pour faire croire que c'est le seul
sujet alors je sais que leur intention
c'est pas ça eux leur intention c'est de
dire c'est quand même con qu'à chaque
fois que on parle du nucléaire ou qu'on
parle du nucléaire dans les histoires de
réchauffement climatique on parle de la
contribution énergie
on parle on met ce sujet soit pas
toujours rappelé j'y voyais que je
comprends votre intention et ça on nie
pas qu'il ya plein de débats sur le
retraitement des déchets mais nous
ferons ce qu'on veut ce qu'ont vu vous
la seule chose qu'on veut dire c'est que
quand on parle d'énergie et de
réchauffement climatique et qu'on parle
de nucléaire faut pas travestir l'état
des connaissances
ok bah vous êtes on est d'accord sur
tout le problème à mon avis c'est que de
ne pas intégrer dans le corps de votre
texte que le reste de le verbaliser
ça va poser un problème cela pose un
problème parce que le lecteur peut vous
faire un procès d'intention implicite et
ils peuvent voir en la bonne
à mon avis une stratégie de
communication sur ces sujets là serait
de faire la phrase complète mais oui
mais nous on est d'accord avec ça et
c'est évident qu'on n'a pas besoin du
vin c'est que ces patchs et notre seul
sujet c'est lorsque comparé de
réchauffement climatique et de
contributions l'énergie c'est juste dans
ce contexte et c'est on veut juste en
fait dire que quand il ya un consensus
scientifique ou même quand le second
quand bien même le consensus ne serait
qu'un consensus qu'il soit rappelé pour
que le citoyen qui axé cette information
sache que ce consensus ne serait-ce que
réglementaires soient mis en débat et
nous serons veut à la limite c'est que
deux bus qu'ils soient remis dans le
dialogue pourquoi ils sont critiqués on
en a pas de problème avec ça mais que au
moins le lecteur soit au courant que bah
ça fait partie de la contrebasse ou de
l'absence donc pas de l'état de la
controverse inclus ce que nous on
considère être un consensus scientifique
ou en dix ans substantifique pour un
consensus règlementaires
on aimerait que quand on parle de momo
fatigue les gens disent rappelle que eh
ben toutes les études pointent le fait
que ça pas plus d'effet propre parce que
ça n'a pas eu d'effet propre extension à
l'effet que son effet est indispensable
il n'y a pas plus qu'elle n'a pas défilé
profs qui sont ce les failles est
attribuable aux effets 10 places et moi
c'est juste sarah appelé le consensus
c'est très bien à la le dialogue
indirect de saut parce que à mon avis si
leur intention est il le sujet qui
veulent défendre si le défendent souvent
ma tribune ne peut pas être compris ne
peut pas être a bien reçu dès lors que
puis occulte tout les prélats le que tu
ne mets pas en avant clairement le sais
que tu as tout à fait conscience de ce
qui est de ce chaos tour et est le truc
c'est que si tu mets en avant le reste
on peut accuser de décider noyer le
poisson
on peut ne pas comprendre ton message un
peu vrai mais c'est quoi le problème
vous énoncer des banalités d'à peu près
tout le monde dit ça à peu près à quoi
donc avoua avoir souhaité être
spécifique et à dd ils ont adopté une
stratégie à mon avis ne pouvait
facilement rencontrer l'incompréhension
plus le fait que en fait ils ont eu
cette idée ce désir de faire des
chroniques dans un contexte particulier
que j'ai rappelé tout à l'heure or on
était autour de mars avril mai juin
juillet le temps est passé ce tir que
dans la lah cela le public
l'électeur potentiel de cette tribune se
sont exposés à d'autres à des débats sur
la désinformation sur la mésinformation
à des articles de presse qui traiter de
ces questions la rage et cette tribune a
été écrite au premier trimestre il me
semblait que si elle voulait toucher un
public lui de journalistes publics rend
public un peu à part c'est le public
elle devait s'actualiser simplement même
parce que les auteurs ont continué à
nourrir leur réflexion sur le sujet
tu peux pas employer les mêmes mots en
janvier 2010 9,1 en juillet 2019
alors qui sait la converse a été
envenimée convenance médiatique et la
controverse
on va dire autour de ces questions de
mal journalisme tu ne veux pas faire ça
et est donc et donc pour ces raisons là
et pour une autre raison qui est fait
que bah voila moi j'ai écris donc ce
gros bouquin s'il parle de mes
informations manuel d'esprit critique à
destination du grand public et des
journalistes et des médecins et de kits
qui lui et du citoyen lambda pour poser
des questions sur est ce que les
informations qui parviennent jusqu'à
nous ont été suffisamment vérifier tel
niveau de confiance etc
jeudi je me suis exposé là dessus j'ai
parlé je me suis professionnellement
exposés et j'ai pris des coups
professionnellement ça les des choses
qui ont été positives avec la
publication de solides hausses ont été
très négatives parce qu'il ya des
chantiers qui sont en senti visé alors
que je les faisais pas particulièrement
doux qui l'ont mal pris quoi et donc de
faire professionnellement j'en ai ça a
été difficile d'abdos et pour développer
mon argumentaire je les fais ans 600
1000 signes j'ai mesuré mes mots lassé
des mots qui sont des les mots de 20
personnes qui ont été soupesée mesuré
sur lesquels moi j'aurais apporté une
petite nuance et je vous dit en fait
j'apporte rien en apportant la signature
surtout que je le ferai pas comme ça un
voyou a été obligé de faire un compromis
quoi un mec tu te parle
enfin vous montre de florian a déjà
signé des tribunes étaient évidemment
pas d'accord avec chacune des virgules
donc voila tu te fais la gueule du monde
je suis d'accord sur le fond l'esprit
qui a animé les autres les autant mais
je suis peut-être même pas d'accord avec
le fait de mettre tous les consensus
dans le même panier et que justement si
tu l'emploi le mot consensus sans le
définir ça va pas et donc pour moi
4000 5000 signes de tribunes produits
ouvrir sa gueule sur le mall journalisme
et sur la mise en formation
c'est pas possible c'est peut-être
possible moi je sais pas faire je pense
pas que vous ayez j'ai pas dit que je
ferais mieux mais je me dis vous lancer
là dedans
moi je vais vous encombrer parce que je
pense que c'est pas comme ça qu'il faut
faire
j'ai essayé de le faire autrement et ça
a pas réussi donc
et en plus voilà je pense que je pense
que cette tribune parce qu'à certains
égards manque de cette réflexivité sur
comment faire en sorte qu'ils aient un
changement dans le monde
j'y crois pas enfin c'est pas que j'y
crois pas je sais que ce que vous voulez
défendre je sais quel est l'esprit qui
nous anime et peut-être que vous avez
raison et que c'est moi qui ai tort mais
mais j'ai tenté de dire la même chose
que vous enfin pas la même chose que
vous
moi j'ai l'enregistrement puis j'ai pas
tenté de dire la même chose que vous
j'ai tenté de dire quelque chose qui va
probablement selon vous et selon moi
dans le même sens c'est à dire arrêtez
de faire en sorte que les journalistes
se réfère à ce qu'on appellerait le
concentré de consensus ils comprennent
la notion de consensus qui vérifient
qu'ils essayent de vérifier l'état de la
controverse avant de commencer à prendre
la plume de m j'ai parlé de la
controverse
j'ai envie de dire ok si c'est ça on est
d'accord mais la façon d'amener le débat
de le mettre en scène de mettre en mots
les licences du débat moi je pense que
elles reflètent une vision du monde qui
est celle de votre collectif une vision
du monde journalistique et celle de
votre collectif et jeu dans mon
cheminement personnel ça ça va pas donc
je j'ai envie de dire que je suis plutôt
pour le fait qu'ils ce qui ouvre alors
qu elle s'écoule que dès que des gens
disaient on a contenu citoyens avant
blogueur avons conscience à un brouillon
exprimé con qui nous semble que le
journaliste n'est pas toujours très très
très bien fait quoi ok cool je pense
quand même que ça que l'impact que ça va
être compliqué quand on regarde quelles
ont été les réactions des journalistes
là les journalistes compagnes par
beaucoup de journalistes en mal pris à
ryadh journalistes ont consigné la
tribune mais il y en a pas mal aussi et
que je pense par milieu des gens qui
étaient visés
tu vas faire le texte l'ont mal pris et
puis y'a des gens qui ont qui ont une
réaction très forte sur le fait que
cette tribune est et scientiste voilà
qu'elle montrait une vision des sciences
qui était naïve
thual manque de réflexion sur le fait
que les savoirs scientifiques sont des
sons produits par plein de choses et
notamment des pressions économiques des
pressions sociales que les révolutions
senti les changements de paradigmes ne
se font pas que parce qu'une vérité
existe que l'économique
il ya un truc qu'on appellerait
consensus qui est magique et donc à hull
pas mais aussi de procès d'intention sur
les représentations qu'avaient les
auteurs du en tête que je ne dis pas
qu'ils n'avaient pas ces représentations
on leur a mis dans la gueule qu'ils
avaient cédée représente 1 106 du monde
tami le débat sur la place publique et
je pense que ça va peut-être avoir des
effets très positifs à long terme ou à
moyen terme donc j'ai pas conscience que
j'ai pas anticipé mais ben tu penses que
c'est est révélée globalement néfastes
en fait je suis pas capable de le
prévoir mais je sais absolument pas
comme ça que j'aurais fait et ça veut
pas dire que je vous préviens ça ne
paraît pas clair en tout cas qu'elle
soit avec les soldes de lombez mais ça
me paraît pas clair qu'elle devrait
laisser ça en fait ça me paraît vraiment
pas clair globalement ce que je pensais
que j'aurais eu le l'intuition tu vas là
souvent tu dis tu demandes dans les
exercices de penser que tu fais aux gens
qui demandent à l'est si tu devais dire
par faire le pari que c'est une bonne
chose ou une mauvaise chose mettez pas
sur la c'est quoi ton paris by their way
j'ai dit ça va parce que je ne dis pas
qu'il parle que des bonnes intentions
que les gens qui sont derrière sais pas
je ne sais pas je pense qu'ils sont
c'est vraiment des gens qui en plus
quand je pense maintenant belge de
valhalla du timing
la formulation que globalement ça va pas
et que pour ça que j'ai pas signé en
fait mon choix mon pari et magasin je
les fais je n'ai pas signé et j'ai
l'impression que les idées qu'ils
auraient sienne de portée je les ai déjà
j'ai essayé moi aussi de les porter
autrement avant je continue à essayer de
les porter plus d'une toute autre façon
et que finalement peut-être que eux
mêmes ont exactement les mêmes
intentions mais que je l'état de mon
parcours personnel fait que j'adopte une
une façon d'être une stratégie
d'expression ou juste une expression ou
un haut niveau de haut niveau de
lassitude aussi peut-être que j'en ai
fait je suis fatigué en fait encore
mieux ne faut pas écarter ça aussi que
mais du coup ça serait pas tâche ne
serait pas un peu de ta faute si tu es
fatigué du midi alors est ce que c'est
de ma faute si sulfate signé par des
gers et ses fins dire la tribune sera et
je vous dis pas qu'ils ont tort je dis
juste que peut-être que j'ai pas dit
qu'ils avaient tort dans l'absolu je dis
juste avec mon système de pensée avec
mon expérience mon passif par mon passif
à tous les sens du terme et de lormont
mon pari bayésiens de fautes il signer
aux forains ou faut-il pas signé m'a
amené à ça mais j'ai jamais dit que
j'avais pas tort et peut-être que et en
plus voilà si l'avenir me prouve que
j'ai tort vous pouvez ressortir cette
vidéo et je m'en excuserai à venir at
est un lâche et hunan en jeu c'est une
réflexion de ne pas signer et néanmoins
je dis je me suis exprimé sur les
réseaux sociaux sur le fait que je me
suis exprimé comment je me suis exprimé
sur cette tribune
alors je n'ai pas signé mais je remarque
quand même tu veux parler des gens qui
font des critiques sur cette tribune et
des critiques qui me semble sérieusement
abusé rien et des gens qui ont de la
gueule sur cette tribune en disant ouais
c'est des scientistes en tout cas cette
tribune elle est écrite
on a l'impression qu'elle écrite par des
scientistes et dans l'impression qu'ils
ont jamais ouvert un dico sur le mot
épistémologie ou alors ils sont arrêtés
avec karl popper est alors il ya des
gens qui l'ont formulée
je me suis dit barre d'un point de vue
d'une stratégie de communication il
n'était pas
je comprends qu'ils pensent ça mais je
sais pas peut-être que bah ça va nourrir
le débat et que dans six mois
et en plus y'a plein de membres de la
tribu india dites nous comment vous
l'auriez formulé mieux nous on est là
pour voir le débat un truc qui me semble
intelligent quoi ainsi ils écoutent ils
savent que je connais pas tous les
membres de la tribune mais y en a deux
au moins j'en pense le plus grand bien
donc je sais que c'est pas ils sont pas
vendus à des lots dick
en tout cas je suis persuadé que leur
intention c'est des intentions qui font
qu'ils petit son vol aller vers plus
d'esprit critique ils veulent lutter
contre la désinformation scientifique
qui voit là je pense qu on partage
beaucoup de valeurs en commun et je suis
si je sais qu'ils sont persuadés de bien
faire et d'aller dans la bonne direction
il s'est peut-être encore exemple voilà
donc ça c'est dit je pense que quand tu
produis une tribune elle doit être aussi
penser en prenons en compte les gens qui
vont interpréter de travers ils font la
brandir pour pour te faire dire ce que
t'as pas dit c'est ça aussi la la
complexité d'écrire un tel objet un
objet de 4000 ou 5000 signes et donc
c'est aussi ça dans mes réserves
l'oeuf les deux arcs de contribuer à
quelque chose sur lesquels epistema je
suis pas tout à fait d'accord enfin
forme de jeu faire comment tu veux sur
lesquels pour les raisons que l'on a
parlé talent je suis pas tout à fait
d'accord sur sur l'essence mais oui moi
personnellement je re considéré qu'il
était intéressante de deux d'expliquer
pourquoi cette notion de consensus
c'est peut-être celle là qu'il faut
expliquer aux journalistes plutôt que de
susciter des consensus
là ils ont piqué tact accord la cité
sainte lucie consensus
à titre d'exemple qui nous semble
important parce qu'ils sont souvent sur
le camp les médias et c'est pas des
consensus domaine nature là l'identite
ce qui permet de considérer que c'est la
même chose
l'objet de consensus elle s'autorise
même avec le recul ces fans 8 ou 10
consensus de même nature donc peut-être
que l'intérêt aurait été de dire nous
aimerions que les journalistes
comprennent que inconscience peut-être
ceci peut-être cela et quand on s'en
suit vont être rappelés
déjà si ça souffle comme ça et puis
ensuite tu donne des exemples
tu dis voilà peut-être que vous ne serez
pas d'accord avec nous mais il nous
semble un homme citoyen que ces
consensus cela existe s'il n'existe pas
facile il existe et il nous semble à
nous qui devrait être rappelé s'il
n'existe pas ex-fn au moins et mettez à
jour l'état du consensus
faites-vous l'état de l'état de l'art
sur ces sujets critiques et les en les
rappelant en rappelant cet état de la
chasse que nous il semble que c'est pas
fait et peut-être qu'on aimait on est
peut-être mal informés peut-être que
c'est vous qui savez détruite mais en
tout cas vous le verbaliser pas et nous
ça nous pose un problème en tant que
citoyen ça nous pose en vrai on n'a pas
le sentiment que qu'on est bien informé
ben voilà c'est ça qui me semble être là
l'esprit du jeu sait plus où je voulais
en venir mais en tout cas tel que ça a
été fait là j'ai le sentiment que ça
pouvait être mal compris mal utilisé ma
lâche 1 et j'ai peut-être tort mais donc
voilà je hais ces terribles durable
alors si tu commences à penser à ce que
les gens vont en penser à tes parents du
manga
ah si il faut le faire il faut le faire
et on prend le cas de la tribune fait
que med quatrième set mais elle a été
interprétée de travers oui elle a été
interprétée travers l été les gens ont
dit ouais c'est une tribune anti
homéopathie ah non c'était pas ça que le
dit hein c'est pas ça elle a dit c'est
une tribune construite charlatans sac
elle dit donc oui cette tribune a été
interprète travers sauf que de par les
gens qui la portait de par les arguments
qui était portée de parler les
stratégies de communication derrière
cercle de qui on va faire intervenir sur
les plateaux pour soutenir notre tribune
alors c'est pas forcément des stratégies
coordonnées mais il ya parleurs parce
que les il ya des grottes des groupes de
mots pâte pour essayer d'être un regain
d'aller discréditer les auteurs et la
réaction des auteurs action bien
légitime des auteurs a été fait
d'exprimer publiquement les deux revers
balisés et de reformuler la salle et
c'est ça qui a eu des effets positifs et
donc même si les gens ont essayé de la
de l'utiliser mal la mauvaise
utilisation que caen n'a été fait a été
contre-productif pour ce qu'il voulait
lui faire dire ce qu'elle disait pas
et donc ça tu peux pas forcément
anticipé m es tu peux percevoir comme
une éventualité surtout construite
ajustements se passe ce cap
ce qu'a eu qu'a été celui là la tribune
à steinhoff ex-alliance sorti il ya
quelques jours et ben intuitivement pour
moi mais je me trompe peut-être elle
difficilement sa compagne est de 2,5 2,7
de ce mouvement de passes que veut à ce
que les gens qui sont concernés dans
l'intention des signes un dessinateur ou
des auteurs de la tribune
les gens les plus concernées les
producteurs d'information de mauvaise
qualité soit ne se sentent pas concernés
soit dit a horreur des d'accord ils font
quand même de la merde soit faut
utiliser des stratégies cognitives pour
la rejeter
on a vu ils ont les auteurs ont été les
signataires ont été accusés d'avoir été
manipulés par des lobbys des réflexions
comme ça quand il était ministre il ya
eu des réactions de de la part des gens
qui sont plutôt d'accord pour le dire à
monsieur scientisme et ils ceux qui se
connectent à l'épistémologie pourquoi
c'est qu'on veut leur gueule ok je pense
que j'arrêterai qu'on progresse et que
désormais c'était très très difficile à
faire un bout d'os sur un texte écrit à
plusieurs c'est compliqué et il pouvait
pas la réactualiser un déjà ils sont
bien ils ont ils on est à 20 pour
arriver à trouver un truc sur lesquels
les vins étaient d'accord et il s'est
passé six mois dans mais je ne sais pas
dit qu'un g en vrai un faudra rappeler
ce time code de monde de la rue j'aurais
pas fait mieux
voilà mais en moins c'est pas parce que
j'aurais pas parce que tu ne fait pas
mieux que tu lâchez pas je pense que
c'est que je fais autre chose
ils ont fait ça j'aurais pas fait mieux
et d'autres gens font d'autres choses et
c'est ça en fait il importe puisque la
coordination de tout ce que veulent les
gens font pour aller dans ce que moi je
considère être le bon sens faire une
information de meilleure qualité
l'important c'est que au global toute la
pointe dans une meilleure direction
je n'ai pas les moyens de savoir si ça
contribue
après je pense que
enfin le grain je pense que c'est ça
reste le balan bénéfique
oui même si ça se discute je fermais par
contre je pense que ce qui est vraiment
important c'est que l'on fasse que ça
aille mieux qu'on fasse mieux que oui et
que ça ça sera juste un point de départ
et pas du tout une destination et du
coup je vais enfin signé le truc c'est
que ça suffit pas a faim et je pense que
le texte est pas suffisant et qu'il va
falloir mais en fait trop facile un
point de départ c'est ça ma question est
donc important s'est toujours montrée
l'interview de ce g ca est ce que c'est
un point de départ
en fait des critiques des
dysfonctionnements du journalisme sont
fait ailleurs on va dire aux souterrains
au sein d'associations devant
l'association des journalistes
scientifiques pour la presse de
l'information dont je ne fais plus
partie pour des diverses pressions et
bien en leur sein il ya des gens qui
oeuvrent à mon avis vraiment vraiment
vraiment gravement dans le bon sens pour
eux on pratique cours que pour une
pratique d'un journalisme scientifique à
destination de l'information du grand
public de très grande qualité avec un
niveau et une rifle des réflexions des
informations pour mieux comprendre les
statistiques des réflexions sur comment
le vulgariser ces constaté que des
changements sont portés en interne
moi je fais mon single avec les
tribunaux mam était l'ami tribunes mais
blog mais les autres des inventions
vidéo mais ma chambre et c'est donc
voilà même pour ça ça peut être
bénéfique les avoir aussi un nouveau
extérieur qui qui qui est de l'avoir
intérieur mais le truc c'est que voilà
la question c'est le pour moi il ya déjà
des points de départ des qu'en fait
c'est comme si on va allumer des feux
ouais c'est ça des feux par mois j'ai
fait un feu je fais des petits feux et
j'ai tenté de faire un bon choix mais je
l'insistance sur le fait que aujourd'hui
il ya pas mal de gens quoi allumer des
feux au centre de beaucoup de rédactions
il ya des pyromanes un délinquant essaie
d'allumer des feux avec parce qu ils
auront iso surtout confrontés à des
ouvrages sur l'esprit critique parce que
ils ont eu dans leur formation
personnelle des cours de philo de
philosophie des sciences et ils se sont
reconvertis dans l'est dans les dents
les dans le journalisme et bien leur
parcours personnel les amène à allumer
des feux
donc je pense que des départs de feu y
en a pleins départs de feu qui voit un
père info de le feu une connotation
négative donc des départs de départ de
tous les départs de mieux voilà c'est
dit pas plus et départ devait eh bien je
ne sais pas et je suis pas j'ai pas
l'impression je ne suis pas certain
vraiment que ça soit 1.2 dépeint des
parts de mieux cette tribune
sinon si j'en avais eu l'intuition tel
un formule 1 le truc il faut dire allez
je suis pas pourquoi je le fais mais je
fais bah moi je pense pas que ce soit un
départ de mieux et quand je vois les
réactions des gens concernés les têtes
parce que je pense pas assez loin
je suis jamais dit que j'étais pas qu'on
commence comme une brique peut-être que
effectivement il ya un bac
enfin une réaction épidermique des deux
ou trois groupes il y en aura une autre
réaction négative dans le groupe mais
ces deux réactions épidermiques qui
s'est enfin vont produire quelque chose
encore après je vais admettre que je ne
suis pas assez intelligent pour voir les
trois coups enfin pour faire du billard
à trois bandes avec mon à courte vue
j'ai l'impression qu'un nous voir que
les deux banques du billard mal dit je
préfère mettre mon énergie ma conscience
et puis may hamm mon expression publique
quoi je m'exprime sur des choses qui
seront entendus par d'autres ailleurs et
comme les deux essais aux sites fallait
les critiques que je te formule là on
les fait de façon publique voilà mais il
faut je les formules pas pour accabler
ou pour soutenir jeu ni les uns ni les
autres je les exprime pour qu'elle soit
entendue comme quelque chose qui amène à
la réflexion collective et encore je
suis ce n'est pas le chocolat pour dire
vous auriez dû faire pour dire moi
j'aurais fait autrement c'est vraiment
on en revient à caumont communiqué
comment produire un changement sur mon
estime qu'un changement est nécessaire
et j'estime qu'il faut gmac est là où
recours puisque tu as confiance est
celui qu'il faut prendre en compte un
certain nombre de anticiper un certain
nombre de conséquences même d'avoir les
anticiper à tort et c'est pour ça que je
le sens je ne me sens pas que c'est un
départ de mieux on sait jamais comment
se propage en feu
on verra mais voilà et je pense qu'il ya
des il ya des risques potentiels